Herzlich Willkommen zum Chaosradio 260, das allen Widerständen zum Trotz heute stattfindet, ja. Wir wollen heute über ein Thema reden, wo die Leute, die über das Thema oder wegen denen über das Thema reden, vielleicht sagen würde, das könnte verhindert werden, wenn die Mächte, die die Welt regieren, da eingreifen. Kurz gesagt wollen wir heute über Lügen, die die Gesellschaft radikalisieren, reden und haben dazu zwei Gäste eingeladen. Zwei Autorinnen, die auch mehr oder regelmäßig Podcasten und Bücher zum Thema herausgebracht haben. Das eine ist Fake Facts wie Verschwörungstheorien denken bestimmen von Katharina Nocun und das andere ist Hasskrieger über den globalen Rechtsextremismus von Karolin Schwarz und beide sind jetzt bei mir hier zu Gast. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. So und das Thema ist schon deshalb schwierig, weil es nicht zum ersten Mal auftaucht. Also die Stichworte sind es gerade Bill Gates, Impfverschwörung, 5G, Grundgesetz abschaffen oder schützen. Man weiß nicht so genau, es geht also um Verschwörungserzählungen oder Verschwörungsmythen und das ist aber so ein Thema, weil es da um Sprache geht, wird es auch gleich am Anfang schwierig. Es ist ja gerade im Nordkontext gibt es das Bild von den Aluhüten oder wie man auch schon sagt, Verschwörungstheoretiker, die Verschwörungstheorien und das Folgbringen. Und genau das aber ist schon die erste Diskussion, die wenn man über dieses Thema redet, man anbringen muss, nämlich man soll nicht mehr Verschwörungstheorie sagen.
Warum? Ja, also ich hab ja ein Buch zusammen mit Pia Lamberti geschrieben, die ist Psychologin und forscht zu dem Thema. Und am Anfang dachte ich auch so, ja lass uns über Verschwörungstheorien schreiben. Dann meinte sie so, ja, das können wir gerne machen. Aber lass uns das doch nicht Verschwörungstheorie nennen, denn das sind keine Theorien im wissenschaftlichen Sinne. Also hierzu muss man wissen, es gibt seit einigen Jahren in der Wissenschaft eine Diskussion, wie sollen wir über dieses Phänomen sprechen? Und da sagen eben mittlerweile viele Forscher so, na ja, lass uns doch das lieber Verschwörungsmythen oder Verschwörungserzählung nennen. Denn bei Theorien ist es ja so, wenn ein Wissenschaftler eine wissenschaftliche These aufstellt, aber eine Theorie aufstellt, dann kann ein anderer Wissenschaftler kommen und dann Beweis erbringen, dass es nicht stimmt. Und dann sagt der Wissenschaftler, okay, okay, okay, ich ziehe das zurück, ich stelle eine neue Theorie auf. Und das Interessante in dieser Szene, wenn man es denn so nennen will, von Verschwörungsgläubigen ist, dass ganz oft Beweise sehr offensichtlich da sind, dass etwas nicht stimmen kann. Dass aber trotzdem man nicht sagt, wir verwerfen das jetzt, sondern es wird weiterhin daran geglaubt. Also so ein klassisches Beispiel ist da so dieser Mythos, dass die Erde flach ist und dann gibt es so diese Erzählung, das soll vertuscht werden durch eine große Verschwörung, wo die NASA dann mit drinsteckt. Natürlich alle Regierungen, es ist dann nicht so wirklich klar, warum sie das machen, aber ist auch egal. Und da kann man ja sagen, das ist ja seit sehr vielen Jahren sehr klar, dass wir nicht auf einer Scheibe leben. Aber diese wissenschaftlichen Beweise, die werden eben nicht anerkannt. Und das große Problem ist eben auch, und das merkt man auch bei dieser flache Erde oder Flat Earth Theory Sache ganz gut, dass ja so gemeinsame Standards, wie wir zu Wissen kommen, also beispielsweise wissenschaftliche Forschung, die werden in manchen Bereichen dann halt auch nicht mehr anerkannt. Weil manche Verschwörungsideologen so weit gehen, dass sie sagen, so naja, die Wissenschaft, die hängt in der jeweiligen Verschwörung mit drin. Alles, was aus der wissenschaftlichen Community kommt, das kann man sowieso nicht glauben.
Und setzt sich das gerade durch oder ist das so ein Diskurs, der unter VerschwörungserzählungsexpertInnen jetzt geführt wird, JournalistInnen vielleicht noch, und dann aber ist es dann eigentlich doch egal?
Ich würde schon sagen, dass sich da in den letzten Jahren viel verändert hat. Also wir haben bei unserem Buch auch ganz klar gesagt, wir wollen im Untertitel Verschwörungstheorien als Wort drin haben, weil Menschen, die betroffen sind, dann erst mal nach diesem Begriff suchen. Das ist eine Frage der Aufwendbarkeit. Aber wir erklären dann auch im ersten Kapitel, warum wir es nicht so nennen wollen. Das Interessante war, in den letzten Wochen haben wir, also Pia und ich, ziemlich viele Interviews mit Journalistinnen und Journalisten geführt. Manchmal war das dann so, man kriegt dann die Zitate, die man dann gegeben hat, dann noch mal zugeschickt. Dann wird gefragt, fühlen sich da richtig wiedergegeben. Dann wurde sehr häufig am Anfang aus Verschwörungserzählung und Verschwörungsmythos, was wir gesagt haben, einfach durchgängig Verschwörungstheorie gemacht. Wir mussten das dann immer umändern. Man muss sagen, innerhalb des letzten Monats ist die Quote der Rückänderung doch sehr radikal zurückgegangen. Man liest sehr viele Berichte jetzt, wo auch Journalistinnen und Journalisten von sich aus sagen, wir nennen das jetzt anders, auch ganz bewusst.
Vielleicht ist das auch zu sagen, die Story, die im Journalismus jetzt gut erzählt werden kann. Weil Journalismus sucht ja manchmal nach, was ist denn jetzt neu daran, und da kann man ja auch darüber reden. Ich hab noch so, das ist so halblustig, aber spielt es vielleicht doch eine Rolle, mir gedacht, Verschwörungstheorien, das lässt sich gut abkürzen. Gerade wenn man im Netz schreibt, so ein VTler, dann weißt du zumindest, wenn man im Thema wandert, das ist bei Verschwörungsmythen oder Verschwörungserzählungen nicht so einfach. Vielleicht brauchst du da noch eine eingängige Abkürzung, damit das in der ganzen Welt jetzt so passiert.
Ich glaube, das hat sich auch nur in bestimmten Teilen der Nerd-Szene wirklich durchgesetzt mit den VTlern. Aber mich erinnert das so ein bisschen insgesamt an diese Diskussion, die wir über Fake News hatten in den letzten drei, vier Jahren. Und die eigentlich um eine Seite verloren hat. Weil im Prinzip gab es die Diskussion darüber, ob man den Begriff Fake News nutzen soll. Ziemlich analog zu dem, was wir jetzt gerade haben, weil in dem Begriff News drinsteckt, dass es eben Nachrichten wären. Was im Zweifelsfall bei Falschmeldungen, über die wir ganz oft reden, auch in einem Zusammenhang mit Brexit und Trump und so geredet haben, eigentlich nicht wirklich Nachrichten, die Falschmeldungen waren. Sondern es waren virale Posts auf Social Media. Es waren gefakte Bilder, aus dem Kontext gerissene Bilder und Videos usw. Und Fake News hat sich aber, und das haben wir in den letzten Wochen ziemlich gut sehen können, komplett durchgesetzt als Begriff, auch im Journalismus.
Was war denn die Alternative?
Die Alternative war in der Regel Desinformation oder Missinformation, was ich auch relativ unglücklich fand, ehrlich gesagt. Ich hab mir das immer so hingedreht, dass es auf den Kontext gepasst hat. Dass ich eben nicht das große Ganze meist bezeichnet hab, sondern eben die konkrete Falschinformation, den konkreten Fake so beziffert hab. Und Fake an sich ist ja auch nicht das Problematische, sondern eher Fake News. Und die Forschung zeigt da zum Beispiel tatsächlich, dass viele Leute unter Fake News ganz unterschiedliche Dinge verstehen. Trotz hat es sich inzwischen tatsächlich durchgesetzt. Desinformation wäre quasi das absichtliche Falschinformieren. Und Missinformation wäre quasi unbeabsichtigt Falschinformationen verbreiten, etwa durch falsch verstandene Inhalte und so weiter.
Im Prinzip ist es ganz interessant, weil das ja auch zeigt, was notwendig ist, damit Dinge, die runde machen oder viral sind, also im Sinne von im Kopf auch kleben bleiben. Das sind halt griffige Begriffe, die halt funktionieren, egal ob sie richtig oder falsch sind. Und so ist es halt mit Fake News und bin gespannt, wie es jetzt wird mit den Verschwörungserzählungen oder ob die Theorien sozusagen, die ja auch sehr griffig als Wort sind, da in den Hintergrund gerückt werden kann. Ist das, sind diese beiden Themenbereiche, also Missinformation und Dissinformation, Dissinformation und Verschwörungserzählungen das selbe?
Nein. Also es gibt fließende Übergänge und Katha kann das sicherlich auch noch ergänzen, aber es ist so, dass es durchaus aus dem Bereich, in dem ich jetzt lange Zeit gearbeitet habe, also so Falschmeldungen im Netz, vor allem das, was eben relativ einfach für Faktenchecker zu widerlegen ist, dass da teilweise eben auch Elemente von Verschwörungserzählungen dabei sind. Zum Beispiel eben Bill Gates ist durchaus eine Figur gewesen, die schon öfter mal da gewesen ist und der eben auch einer geheimen Elite zugeschrieben wird, die planhaft handelt, um die Geschicke der Welt zu lenken. George Soros ist so ein Mensch, der immer wieder auch in Falschmeldungen vorkommt. Aber es gibt eben auch Falschmeldungen, die keine Verschwörungstheorien sind oder Verschwörungserzählungen. Jetzt hab ich selber gedacht. Das wäre das Trinkspiel für heute Abend gewesen. Chance verpasst. Also es gibt quasi durchaus noch Unterschiede, aber auch fließende Übergänge, will ich sagen. Und wir haben, ich hab mich ja viel mit Verschwörungserzählungen, aber auch Falschmeldungen zum Thema Asyl beschäftigt ab 2016. Und da war es eben so, dass es auch so eine Entwicklung gab über die Zeit. Also dass es zu Anfang 2015, 16 ganz viele Falschmeldungen waren über Geflüchtete, die die Straftaten begehen oder die ganz viel staatliche Hilfen oder Zuwendungen bekommen. Und dann wechselte das so ein Stück weit rüber in Verschwörungserzählungen. Und dann gab es ganz oft zum Beispiel diese Erzählung, dass es einen Geheimplan der Regierung gebe, 12 Millionen Afrikaner nach Deutschland zu bringen. Und da gab es auch schon durchaus Entwicklungen in die Richtung.
Ja, also man kann schon sagen, dass es auf jeden Fall zwei vollkommen unterschiedliche Phänomene sind. Es gibt aber eben diesen Zusammenhang, dass viele Verschwörungsideologen sich sehr oft eben auf Falschmeldungen berufen. Oder teilweise Meldungen verbreiten, wo dann irgendwo so ein winziger kleiner Kern ist, aber drumrum wirklich Zusammenhänge gesponnen werden, wo man einfach sagen muss, das ist vollkommen weit hergeholt. Und das, was Caro ja auch angesprochen hat, dieser Mythos von einem angeblichen großen Austausch oder einer angeblichen Umvolkung ist ja auch in der rechtsextremen Szene eine unglaublich populäre und auch sehr wirkmächtige Verschwörungserzählung, wo es eben darum geht, dass behauptet wird, es gibt eben diesen geheimen großen Plan von unterschiedlichen politischen Entscheidern. Mal ist es Angela Merkel, mal ist es eine jüdische Weltverschwörung, wo dann Angela Merkel irgendwie auch mit drin hängt. Und ganz oft ist George Soros, der sehr bekannte US-Investor, jüdisch-ungarisch-amerikanische Investor, der eben auch die Open Societies Foundations gegründet hat, so eine der größeren Stiftungen, die sich im Bereich Antirassismus auf eine Gesellschaft einsetzt. Diese Akteure werden dann als Player identifiziert, die dann angeblich so einen großen Plan haben. Und dann werden eben auch bestimmte Meldungen oder auch Falschmeldungen dann da reingewebt. Wenn es beispielsweise heißt, so ein klassisches Beispiel, da gab es auch viele Nachrichten über angebliche Betrügereien bei Asylbescheiden, wo sich dann später rausgestellt hat, na ja, da war eigentlich gar nichts. Da wurde halt etwas auch sehr aufgebauscht. Wenn jemand durch die Brille einer Verschwörungserzählung solche Nachrichten anschaut, dann passt das natürlich genau zu dem Weltbild, was man irgendwo hat. Man vermutet da ein großer Plan und dann sagt man direkt, okay, das ist jetzt auf jeden Fall ein Indiz dafür, dass das stimmen muss. Das heißt, es gibt da eben einen Zusammenhang, obwohl es zwei unterschiedliche Sachen sind. Oft sind aber die Akteure, die so etwas verbreiten, die haben eben sehr große Schnittmengen.
Ich würde gerne über die Akteure selber sprechen wollen, weil da gibt es jetzt von den Dingen, die ihr bis jetzt erzählt habt, müsste es eigentlich so drei verschiedene geben, nämlich die, die absichtlich Missinformationen oder Verschwörungserzählungen in die Welt setzen, um politische Ziele voranzutreiben, im weitesten Sinne, sage ich jetzt mal. Aber gibt es dann auch Menschen, die sowas begegnen und dann, wie soll ich sagen, wieder besseren Wissens glauben und dann weiterverbreiten, weil es in ihr Weltbild passt?
Ich finde das schwierig zu trennen, weil von außen kannst du es kaum bewerten, ob jemand das verbreitet, weil er eine politische Agenda hat und eigentlich es besser wissen müsste. Oder ob er wirklich dran glaubt. Ein klassisches Beispiel ist diese wiederkehrende Erzählung einer angeblichen Verschwörung rund um Wahlbetrug. Wobei man sagen muss, es gibt Länder, wo Wahlbetrug stattfindet, es gibt Unregelmäßigkeiten. Aber es gibt eben auch ganz oft, vor allem von Seiten von rechtsextremen Parteien, diesen Aufschrei grundsätzlich nach fast jeder Wahl, wo einfach behauptet wird, hier gab es eine große Verschwörung und deshalb haben wir so schlecht abgeschnitten. Und da kann man schlecht von außen bewerten, ob diejenigen, die das verbreiten, beispielsweise auch manchmal Donald Trump, ob diejenigen, die das verbreiten, das wirklich glauben oder ob das eine politische Agenda ist. Und im Endeffekt, deshalb finde ich aber auch diese Unterscheidung zwischen Desinformation und Falschmeldung an der Stelle auch schwierig, weil es oftmals eine Vermutung ist, dass ich jemandem unterstelle, dass er das bewusst macht. Ich kann es in vielen Fällen eben auch nicht nachweisen.
Ich glaube zusätzlich muss man sagen, also es gibt ja durchaus Menschen, die geschäftsmäßig versuchen, Dinge in die Welt zu setzen und versuchen, sich zu bereichern durch irgendwelche angeblichen Wunderheilmittel und so weiter, wobei es auch da eine Grauzone gibt und Leute gibt, die daran wahrscheinlich glauben. Grundsätzlich würde ich aber auch sagen, dass vieles von dem, was ich an Falschmeldungen wiederum gesehen habe, gerade auch aus dem Bereich Asyl, dass es da eben gerade unter den Verbreitern super viele gibt, die das glauben. Es gibt aber eben auch einzelne Akteure, die zum Beispiel den Infokrieg erklärt haben. Was ist das? Also die quasi sagen, sie benutzen Informationen oder falsche Informationen als Waffe. Die versuchen, organisiert Falschmeldungen in die Welt zu setzen oder zu verbreiten. Und es gibt verschiedene Reaktionen, wie Menschen darauf reagieren, wenn sie darauf angesprochen werden, dass sie eine falsche Information verbreitet haben. Also es gibt die Möglichkeit, dass man sich entweder entschuldigt oder das klar stellt und zurücknimmt. Es gibt die Möglichkeit, dass man es einfach tonlos, wortlos löscht. Oder es gibt die Möglichkeit, wie den ehemaligen Sprecher der Bundestagsfraktion der AfD, der gesagt hat, naja, wenn es halt irgendwie ins Bild passt, in die Erzählung, dann ist es ja okay. Solange es passt, sehen wir da kein Problem. Und das war bezogen auf ein Bild, das sie verbreitet haben von einer angeblich gewaltbereiten Antifa-Frau, die eigentlich zur Jungen Union gehörte und ein Video über die Rote Fluche in Hamburg gemacht hat. Und da ein Pflasterstein in der Hand hielt. Aber es hat halt ins Bild gepasst. Insofern war es dann egal. Also ich finde, da ist es auch nochmal wichtig zu unterscheiden.
Aus meiner Sicht ist es am einfachsten, sag ich mal, zu unterscheiden, es ist Desinformation, also es ist Absicht oder nicht, bei staatlichen Akteuren. Und da haben wir ja auch in der Geschichte so eine ganze Reihe von Beispielen gehabt, wo offensichtlicher Quatsch verbreitet wurde. Also ich weiß noch, meine Eltern, die haben mir erzählt als Kind, dass es in Polen so eine Erzählung gab. Also wir hatten so einen Schrebergarten, und dann musste ich halt Kartoffelkäfer sammeln, wie das halt so ist als Kind. Und meine Eltern so zu mir so, ja, also in Polen haben sie uns immer erzählt, die Kartoffelkäfer, die kommen von den Amis, und die werden mit Flugzeugen über dem Land abgeworfen, ja. Und dann hab ich im Zuge der Buchrecherche auch noch mal so ein bisschen angeschaut, in welchen Ländern war das noch verbreitet. Und man muss sagen, das war in ziemlich vielen Ländern so im Osten verbreitet. Also in der DDR gab's das, in Tschechien gab's das. Und da wurde richtig Propagandamaterial gedruckt. So mit Aufklebern, Informationsgroschüren und Veranstaltungen, Plakaten, ne. Also so die große Propaganda-Schlacht, wo man sagen musste, naja, so etwas müsste ein staatlicher Akteur relativ gut wissen, ob das stimmt oder nicht. Und da liegt schon nahe zu sagen, so naja, das ist schon wahrscheinlich Desinformation gewesen, um halt irgendwie auch zu rechtfertigen, wenn die Ernte mal schlecht ausgefallen ist oder die Versorgungslage einfach nicht so optimal war.
Jetzt haben wir so mehr oder weniger implizit bestimmte ErzählerInnen von Verschwörungserzählungen oder Desinformationen so markiert. Und ich frage mich, ob das alles ist. Es gibt einerseits Menschen oder Institutionen oder staatliche Stellen, die eine Agenda haben und das benutzen, wie du es gerade erzählt hast. Dann ist jetzt schon von Karolin, also dein Buch handelt ja vor allen Dingen auch über Rechtsextremismus, eben das in der rechtsextremen Szene, das auch als Werkzeug benutzt wird oder auch halt sozusagen gerne geglaubt wird. Aber es gibt ja, wenn wir über Verschwörungsmärchen kann man vielleicht sogar sagen, reden, so diesen ganzen, diesen Bereich, wo es wirklich sehr wirr wird, also flache Erde oder komische Impfdinge, die angeblich passieren und so. Kann man das noch als Gruppe irgendwie kategorisieren? Oder gibt es da ein Wort für? Oder ist das was anderes oder fallen die alle? Unter staatlicher Stelle fällt es nicht und sind Esoteriker oder Verschwörungsmärchengläubige immer rechtsextrem?
Nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Es gibt viele Verschwörungserzählungen, wo man sagen kann, die haben jetzt keinen direkten Bezug zu Antisemitismus oder Rassismus. Ja, es gibt, aber man muss sagen, dass diese Struktur von vielen Verschwörungserzählungen sehr anschlussfähig ist für rassistische oder antisemitische Welterklärungsmodelle. Denn oft geht es darum, dass man unterstellt, es gibt eine kleine Gruppe von sehr mächtigen Menschen oder eine mächtige Einzelperson, die angeblich eine große Gestaltungsmacht hat. Und die hat im Geheimen einen Plan, um der Welt zu schaden. Das passt eben auch zu diesen Stereotypen, die es im Bereich Antisemitismus gibt. Stichwort Verschwörungserzählungen, wo es dann heißt, einige mächtige jüdische Familien, die kontrollieren alles. Da muss man ganz genau anschauen, wer diese angeblichen Akteure in der jeweiligen Verschwörungserzählung sind. Ich muss sagen, wir waren da teilweise sehr erstaunt bei einigen Bereichen, die wir uns angeschaut haben. Unter anderem waren wir auf einer Messe, wo es um Esoterik ging, hier in Berlin. Da sind wir in eine Veranstaltung zum Thema Impfen gegangen. Da war recht klar, dass der Referent, der interessanterweise auch selbst Arzt war, die AfD eher für nicht rechts hält. Im Vortrag zum Thema Impfen wurde plötzlich ein Plakat von der Deutschen Bahn gezeigt, wo dann Menschen mit dunkler Hautfarbe zu sehen sind. Vollkommen zusammenhangslos hat er sich darüber ischofiert, was das denn abbilden soll, welche Gesellschaft. Die Leute im Publikum haben geklatscht. Das waren eher so Leute im Publikum, wo man denken würde, die kommen jetzt gerade von der Goa-Party oder vom Hippiefest. Das fand ich dann doch schon interessant. Das beobachtet man ja auch jetzt gerade bei den Diskussionen über die Demonstrationen der letzten Woche, wo dann gesagt wurde, na ja, das ist eher linkes Spektrum oder die sehen doch gar nicht aus wie rechts. Und da muss ich sagen, nach unserer Recherche, es gibt eben sehr starke Verknüpfungen, gab es schon immer, zwischen einzelnen esoterischen Gruppen und der rechtsextremen Szene. Es ist klar, dass die rechtsextreme Szene in diesen Bereichen ja auch ganz klar bildert. Also wenn jemand, sag ich mal, vorimpregniert ist mit so einem Glauben, es gibt eine große Verschwörung, das System belügt uns, die Presse auch. Das sind ja ähnliche Dinge, die auch in rechtsextremistischen Gruppen kommuniziert werden. Dieser Mythos von wir sind eine kleine Gruppe, wir kennen die Wahrheit. Das passt eben sehr gut zu der Erzählung. Da muss man halt wirklich aufpassen bei einzelnen Gruppen, wie das bei denen innen drin ausschaut. Wir haben auch mit einer Psychologin gesprochen, die ist zu einem Impfstampftisch gegangen, in der Nähe von Mainz und wollte sich mal angucken, was für Leute da so hingehen. Das war bunt gemischt. Es waren Eltern, die gesagt haben, sie sind sich nicht sicher, ob sie ihr Kind impfen wollen. Dazu muss man sagen, das ist an sich keine Verschwörungserzählung. Wenn man aber tiefer gräbt, findet man in solchen Gruppen oft den Glauben, warum erfahren wir denn nicht, dass das Impfen angeblich gefährlich ist. Da werden Beweise unterdrückt und die Wissenschaft, die Politik und alle hängen mit der Pharmaindustrie unter einer Decke. Da hat dann ein Mitglied dieser Gruppe gesagt, es gibt die Möglichkeit, den Impfzwang zu umgehen. Wir müssen uns nur einer bestimmten Religionsgruppe anschließen. Da meinte jemand anders, ich habe nach dieser Religionsgruppe recherchiert, das scheinen wohl Rechtsextreme zu sein. Dann meinte ein anderer, wenn ich mich dafür nicht impfen lassen muss, dann mache ich trotzdem mit, das ist mir egal. Da hat man gemerkt, das wird sehr merkwürdig. Da sind Verbindungen, die man von außen nicht erahnen würde. Es ist auf keinen Fall dasselbe. Aber die Berührungspunkte in der esoterischen Szene, die sind größer als man denkt. Es gibt auch etwas wie braune Esoterik. Es gibt auch Anastasia, nennen die sich. Das ist eine rechtsextreme Gruppe, die sich auf solche Schriften von so einem Guru beruft, der 1A antisemitischen Quatsch davon sich gibt in seinen Büchern. Da heißt es, die Juden würden die Welt kontrollieren. Wie man es eben kennt, von Rechtsextremen. Die sehen nach außen aus wie Hippies, die irgendwo siedeln. Wenn man sich anguckt, was in den Büchern steht, an die diese Leute glauben, dann fällt man vom Glauben ab.
Aber dann sind wir jetzt doch wieder bei dem Punkt, dass der Weg ins Rechtsextreme zumindest nicht weit ist. Aber trotzdem noch mal versucht zu fragen, wer bringt das in die Welt, wer glaubt daran? Kann man das irgendwie sagen? Ich hab selber auch noch das Problem, dass ich gar nicht richtig greifen kann, was Verschwörungserzählungen sind. Weil ich selber relativ hilflos bin dagegen, wenn man so was sieht. Wenn ich so was sehe, ist mein erster Impuls. Das ist doch totaler Quatsch. Und ich kann mir sozusagen nicht vorstellen, wie ist der innere Zustand von Menschen, die auf so was reinfallen. Anders kann ich es gar nicht nennen. Gibt es darüber auch Erkenntnisse? Oder sozusagen gemeinsame Merker, wo man sagt, Menschen, die so etwas glauben, die so was begegnen und dem nicht sofort widersprechen können, vielleicht, die haben bestimmte Merkmale oder die haben eine bestimmte Geschichte oder kommen aus einer bestimmten Ecke. Gibt es da irgendwas? Oder ist es einfach was, das kann jedem passieren?
Es gibt Studien aus der Psychologie, die haben sich angeguckt, was für Zusammenhänge gibt es. Man muss da allerdings sagen, man kann nicht sagen, ob es da einen kausalen Zusammenhang gibt. Das sind eben auch nur Durchschnittswerte bei Studien, wo dann halt mehrere hundert Teilnehmer befragt werden. Man kann jetzt nicht sagen, es gibt da einen eins Art Zusammenhang. Sondern man kann eben nur sagen, das ist so eine gewisse Kausalität. Es gibt da eben so eine Beobachtung, dass Menschen, wenn sie mit Situationen von Kontrollverlust konfrontiert werden, das heißt, wenn sie das Gefühl haben, ihnen entgleitet so ein bisschen die Kontrolle über die Situation, sie fühlen sich machtlos, hilflos, sie haben Angst, dann neigen sie eher dazu, an Verschwörungserzählungen zu glauben. Da gab es Studien, zu diesem Punkt gibt es tatsächlich sehr viele unterschiedliche Studien, die es in ganz vielen Variationen ausgetestet haben. Teilweise wurden Gruppen-Fragebögen vorgelegt oder Texte, wo die eine Gruppe an Situationen erinnert wurde, wo man eher die Kontrolle über das Leben hatte. Beispielsweise ich entscheide, was für Musik ich höre. Ich entscheide, was ich im Leben mache. Die zweite Gruppe wurde eher mit Aussagen zum Thema Naturkatastrophen und Krankheiten konfrontiert. Also Situationen, in denen man Kontrollverlust erlebt. Da konnte man einen Unterschied sehen. Die eine Gruppe hat eher Verschwörungserzählungen zugestimmt als die andere. Dann gab es noch andere Beobachtungen, dass man auch, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr euch das noch kennt vom Augenarzt, wo man Bilder vorgelegt bekommt und dann wird gesagt, da ist ein Muster drin, du musst das jetzt finden. Ob man in der Lage ist, ein Muster auf Farbunterschieden zu erkennen, damit wird gemessen, ob man gut Farbunterschiede sehen kann. In einem psychologischen Test wurden Leute Muster vorgelegt und dann wurde gesagt, in diesem Muster sind Bilder versteckt. Und zwar in ein paar von diesen Bildern. Das sind Gegenstände, beispielsweise ein Schiff, ein Auto oder ein Haus. Dann gab es wieder diese zwei Gruppen. Die einen wurden in eine Kontrollverlustsituation gesteckt und die anderen eben nicht. Dann stellte sich heraus, dass die Leute, die diesen Kontrollverlust erlebt hatten, eher Muster gesehen haben, wo keine waren. Ich finde, das ist eine interessante Beobachtung, die man als Außenstehender bei Menschen beobachtet, die sehr tief drin in einer Verschwörungserzählung sind und dann plötzlich Zusammenhänge sehen, wo keine sind. Da kann man schon sagen, wissenschaftliche Studien deuten darauf hin, dass das auch etwas damit zu tun hat, wie wir gerade unsere Situation im Leben wahrnehmen. Bei anderen Studien konnte gezeigt werden, dass einige Menschen auch so ein instrumentelles Verhältnis zu Verschwörungen haben. Natürlich nicht alle, das ist immer ein statistischer Wert. Aber es gibt eben Menschen, für die scheint das so eine Art und Weise zu sein, auch eine gewisse Bedeutung zu sehen. Man erzählt sich ja quasi auch so eine Art Heldengeschichte. Wenn ich einer von wenigen bin, die wirklich den Durchblick haben und der Rest ist halt dumm oder Teil der Verschwörung, dann macht mich das natürlich besonders. Das ist eben für einige Menschen, scheint das attraktiv zu sein. Studien haben eben gezeigt, dass Menschen, die eher dazu neigen, auch zu sagen, ich möchte mich bewusst von der Masse abheben, dass die eher offener für solche Sachen sind. Das heißt natürlich nicht, dass jeder, der alternativ Musik hört oder sagt, ich bin erst mal kritisch gegenüber dem, was ich in der Zeitung lese, dass der jetzt automatisch ein Verschwörungsideologe ist. Das heißt auch nicht, dass ein kritischer Blick etwas Falsches ist. Ganz im Gegenteil. Aber da muss man schon sagen, die Dosis macht das Gift.
Könnte man das private Anekdote sagen, dass Menschen, die sich vor allen Dingen darin gefallen, anders als die anderen zu sein, da so hinrutschen können? Weil gerade in gut erklärten Gebieten, so was wie Impfen, finde ich da ein ganz praktikables Beispiel, da ist ja eigentlich alles klar. Wenn man da anders sein will als alle anderen, dann bleibt nur noch das als Ausweg, dass man auf so eine ganz wirre Ebene kommt.
Ja, so ganz kann man diesen Zusammenhang... Es gibt unglaublich viele Faktoren, die da reinspielen. In der Psychologie gibt es eben auch Studien, die sich angeschaut haben, spielt Langeweile eine Rolle. Oder spielt Intelligenz eine Rolle. Spielt Alter eine Rolle, Geschlecht. Da kann man sagen, es gibt da eben Zusammenhänge. Aber man kann insgesamt sagen, der stärkste Zusammenhang ist schon bei dieser Kontrollverlust-Geschichte. Das ist etwas, das kann jedem, unabhängig von Bildung, unabhängig vom Alter, unabhängig vom Einkommen, wobei man allerdings sagen muss, dass natürlich, wenn ich gut situiert bin und auch eine gute Ausbildung hab, dann hab ich auch ganz andere Möglichkeiten im Leben als jemand, der ein geringes Einkommen hat. Es gibt Studien, die beispielsweise sagen, wenn du eine geringe Intelligenz hast oder einen geringen Bildungsrat, dann bist du anfälliger. Aber das kann man auch über diese Kontrollverlust-Geschichte erklären. Weil man sagt, wenn ich weniger Optionen im Leben hab, aufgrund von weniger Zugang zu Bildung, dann hab ich eben auch weniger Kontrolle.
Das andere, das kam mir gerade so ein, kommt mir bekannt vor, es gibt auch sehr gut situierte, in einem sehr sicheren Leben befindliche, eher sich selbst für intellektuell, sind das auch, aber halten sich auch selbst dafür. Die dann so viel Spaß daran haben, das extrem zu denken, dass sie dann empfänglich dafür sind. Also im Sinne von, das wird man ja noch mal nachdenken dürfen. Und dann sozusagen dahin kommen.
Ja, also das muss man sich dann halt im Einzelfall anschauen. Ich finde es schwierig, jetzt hier allgemeine Aussagen zu machen. Und das ist auch das Problem, wenn man über dieses Phänomen spricht. Also man kann halt schon sagen, es gibt eben allgemeine Zusammenhänge, die man auch messen kann, die in Studien seit Jahrzehnten auch immer wieder gezeigt werden konnten, es gibt auch eine unterschiedliche Variation. Aber die Einzelfälle sind ja total unterschiedlich. Also wir haben da junge Eltern, die einfach verunsichert sind. Und dann halt irgendwie durch einen Zufall in dieses Milieu, der Leute kommt, die an eine Impfverschwörung glauben. Soziales Umfeld spielt da eine Rolle. Ganz viele unterschiedliche Faktoren. Und man weiß eben auch beispielsweise bei Menschen aus der Reichsbürgerszene, so bei qualitativen Untersuchungen, da haben eben auch einige, wo viele Anhänger gesagt, das ist ein privater Schicksalsschlag. Oftmals der Auslöser war, warum sie sich mit diesem Milieu auseinandergesetzt haben und dann irgendwann geglaubt haben, dass Deutschland nur eine GmbH sein und privater Schicksalsschlag. Das kann eben auch natürlich Trennung sein. Also mein Ehepartner verlässt mich überraschend oder stirbt. Oder ich verliere meinen Job. Und in solchen Umbrüchen haben wir natürlich so einen Kontrollverlust. Und dann sind wir plötzlich anfällig. Aber du hast das Beispiel gebracht mit jemand, der gut situiert ist, gebildet. Da habe ich jetzt zwei Faktoren gehört. Ich kenne die anderen nicht. Ich finde, die Menschen sind sehr unterschiedlich. Und auch dieses Phänomen ist extrem unterschiedlich. Und da allgemeine Aussagen zu treffen, abseits von bestimmten psychologischen Faktoren, wie Kontrollverlust oder eben den Hang von Menschen auch für große Ereignisse eher eine große Ursache zu vermuten, das kann man machen. Aber bei anderen Sachen finde ich schwierig, so einen Einzelfall allgemein zu bewerten. Und ganz davon abgesehen in der Psychologie ist das auch hochgradig verpönt, Ferndiagnosen zu machen. Wird ja auch gerne bei Prominenten wie Trump gemacht. Ja, sowas kann man einfach nicht machen.
Das war jetzt natürlich gar nicht mein Bedürfnis, sondern das war der Versuch, noch mal zu fassen, was du gesagt hast von diesen Menschen, die sich darin gefallen, besonders zu sein. Das war nur noch mal der Versuch, das zu fassen. Ich will jetzt gerne fragen wollen, Karolin, hast du da jetzt auch etwas zu sagen dazu, noch etwas dazu zu fügen, oder ist das so, wo du sagst, ja, so ist es halt?
Ja, ich hab tatsächlich nicht das Buch über die Verschwörungsmythen geschrieben. Deshalb lasse ich Katha da auch einfach gern den Vortritt und spreche eher über den Teil, wo Rechtsextreme da ins Spiel kommen.
Genau, die Frage wäre zum Beispiel, sind die Beweggründe für, oder andersrum, ist das Abgleiten in den Rechtsextremismus und in diese Geschichten, die dann auch damit verbreitet werden, kann das auch aus einer ähnlichen Ecke kommen, wie eben von diesen Verschwörungserzählungen, dass man also den Kontrollverlust im eigenen Leben kompensiert, indem man dann Rechtsextrem wird?
Vor allem, glaube ich, ist es aber eine Frage der Herangehensweise und auch der strategischen Herangehensweise von Rechtsextremen, Rechtsradikalen selbst. Das heißt, es gibt formulierte Strategien von Leuten, die sagen, wir sprechen sie erst mal mit mit Anschlussfähigeren Themen auf den großen Plattformen an. Das sind halt eben so Asyl-Dinge, die... Also wir wissen, antimuslimischer Rassismus ist in der Mitte der Gesellschaft Anschlussfähig. Da gibt es auch nichts schönes zu reden. Versuchen sie darüber und gehen dann eben in die verschwörungsideologische Ecke weiter. Dann ist es eben der große Austausch dieser Mythos verschiedener antisemitische Verschwörungserzählungen usw. Und dazu kommt eben auch, dass es einfach sichtbar ist, dass rechtsextreme Akteure versuchen eben verschiedene verschwörungsideologische Spektren für sich zu vereinnahmen. es gab letztes Jahr bei dieser größeren Impfgegner-Demo in Berlin gab es rechtsextreme Akteure, die dort aktiv waren, die Sticker verteilt haben usw. Es gibt diesen einen Aktivisten aus Halle, der einen T-Shirt und Sticker-Shop betreibt. Und eben auch zahlreiche Verschwörungsideologen mit eben Merchandise beliefert. Also der war glaube ich der Erste in Deutschland, der halt QAnon-Shirts vertrieben hat. man versucht eben gezielt, Leute für sich zu gewinnen, auch aus diesem Spektrum. Und hat die so für sich entdeckt als mögliche neue Anhänger.
nochmal die Warnung von Kattascha, dass man nicht zu viel verallgemeinern kann. Aber man könnte schon schließen, es gibt bestimmte Situationen, die anscheinend damit zusammenhängen, wie gut jemand an Verschwörungserzählungen glaubt. Und eben diese Menschen sind auch besonders interessant für Rechtsextreme, weil sie sich halt beeinflussen lassen. Ich würde als nächstes gerne diese Situation des Kontrollverlusts nochmal aufgreifen und dann konkret machen, weil die Zeit der Corona-Krise natürlich das in einem ganz großen Extrem ist. Das Gefühl, dass man das eigene Leben nicht mehr unter Kontrolle hat, weil da so eine Sache passiert, die einfach unfassbar viel größer ist als wir alle, kann man sagen. Wir hören vorher aber eine kleine Musik, bevor wir das machen. Die kommt heute vom Album Since Working Overtime von Lee Rose Weir. Und der erste Track ist Sunset City. So, damit herzlich willkommen zurück im Chaos Radio 260, wo es um Verschwörungserzählungen gibt oder Lügen, die die Gesellschaft radikalisieren. Kattascha und Karolin sind bei mir zu Gast und wir haben in der ersten halben Stunde so grob gelernt, dass es also nicht unbedingt einen kausalen Zusammenhang, aber zumindest eine Beobachtung gibt, dass Kontrollverlust im Leben da mit einhergehen kann, dass man an Verschwörungserzählungen glaubt. Und jetzt haben wir gerade die Corona-Krise, es gibt zwar Lockerungen und manchmal fühlt es sich vielleicht so an, als wäre sie vorbei, aber die unser Leben momentan gerade verändert und tatsächlich als riesengroßer Kontrollverlust einfach beschrieben werden kann. Und jetzt haben wir wahrscheinlich alle irgendwie irgendwas gehört von diesen Hygienedemos, wo Menschen rumlaufen, die Verschwörungsmythen verbreiten oder glauben. Ich würde jetzt ganz gerne das mal aufgreifen und abfragen, was sind denn da eben diese Verschwörungsmythen, die sich jetzt gerade erzählt werden?
Also es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Mythen, die gerade die Runde machen. Viele davon sind eigentlich auch gar nicht so neu, sondern wurden eigentlich abgeändert auf den aktuellen Kontext. Und was wir auch sehen können, ist, dass es eben reichlich Verschwörungsmythen und Verschwörungserzählungen gibt. Das liegt einfach auch daran, dass wir quasi in einer Langzeitkrise uns befinden. Also wir kennen das zum Beispiel aus Naturkatastrophen, eben Krisensituationen wie Anschläge, Terroranschläge, Amokläufe, wo eben das auch immer eine Rolle spielt. Aber jetzt haben wir eben eine Situation, in der das wochenlange Fall ist. Viele von den Sachen, die wir gerade aber sehen, sind auch nicht neu. Also es wird gerade viel über mögliche neue Impfungen gesprochen, geschrieben, auch viel monologisiert in YouTube-Videos. Bill Gates spielt da eine große Rolle. Interessanterweise habe ich 2017 meinen ersten Faktencheck damals bei Correktiv noch über Bill Gates und Impfen geschrieben. War ein schönes Flashback. Also das heißt, es ist vieles nicht neu. Es wird jetzt immer wieder ein altes Fake-Zitat von Bill Gates hochgeholt, der angeblich gesagt hätte, dass Impfen dazu da ist, die Bevölkerung zu reduzieren. Vieles, auch gerade im rechtsextremen Spektrum, geht es darum, dass diese Kontaktbeschränkungen zum Beispiel dazu eingeführt wurden, um den Kapitalismus neu zu ordnen. Also das ist auch eine Erzählvariante. Es gibt verschiedene Verschwörungserzählungen zum Ursprung des Virus. Also sowohl Biowaffe als auch chinesischer Unfall, als auch die Israelis stecken dahinter, oder auch die USA. Also das wechselt ab und zu je nach Szene quasi. Und es gibt eben ganz oft den Fall, dass das so inkorporiert wurde. Also zum Beispiel, dass viele von den Erzählungen, die wir jetzt sehen, auch eingefügt worden in diese Riesenerzählung von QAnon zum Beispiel, die ja auch schon vorher da war.
Du musst glaube ich, weil das zum Zeitmarkt gesagt hat, dass auch nicht jeder weiß, was QAnon eigentlich ist.
Ja, also ein paar Leute kennen wahrscheinlich noch Pizzagate, also die Verschwörungserzählung des Hillary Clinton zusammen mit anderen aus dem Keller einer Pizzeria heraus, einen Kindermissbrauchsring betreibt. Und diese Verschwörungserzählung, die ja auch zu Gewalttaten geführt hat, ist im Prinzip in so eine riesen Verschwörungserzählung eingefügt worden, nämlich QAnon und das begann so mit den sogenannten Q-Drops, also kleinen, rätselhaften Informationsfetzen, die auf einem Imageboard gepostet wurden. Und aus diesem Bereich gab es erst in den USA relativ viele Anhänger, die geglaubt haben, Donald Trump sei jetzt der, der die Leute vom Deep State, also dieser geheimen Elite, die die Geschicke der Welt lenkt, befreien soll. Also Donald Trump ist quasi in dieser Erzählung der Held. Und wir sehen gerade tatsächlich, dass QAnon-Gruppen und Kanäle auf Facebook und Telegram deutlich Zulauf haben, auch in Deutschland. Also ich hätte das vorher noch viel mehr als Randerscheinungen geschrieben, als es jetzt aktuell tatsächlich ist.
Über die Plattform reden wir gleich nochmal, aber das ist sozusagen eine Sache, die da auch dann vorkommt. Mir ist selber noch was passiert, wo ich mich frage, woher kommt das? Und zwar war ich an einer Tankstelle und habe dort bezahlt, hab natürlich meine Maske aufgehauen, reinzugehen. Dann ging jemand anders rein, hatte keine Maske auf. Ich hab ihn darauf hingewiesen und dann sagte er, das sei ja keine Pflicht. Dann meinte ich, das stimmt vielleicht, aber es ist total respektlos gegenüber den Mitarbeitern und drinnen. Und bin dann in mein Auto gestiegen und er kam aber noch mal raus und sagte, du siehst gar nicht aus wie ein Medienopfer, du bist aber eins, es gibt kein Corona.
Ja, das gibt's auch als Frischwürgungserzählung. Und es gibt Leute, die beides glauben natürlich auch.
Und das hat dich aber sozusagen total fassungslos gemacht. Und ich verstehe gar nicht, was ist denn der Sinn dahinter?
Also das ist tatsächlich eine Erzählung, die relativ viel unterwegs ist auch. Und das hängt so ein bisschen aber auch zusammen mit diesen, mit den Erzählungen, die wir auch schon seit Monaten sehen, dass es Corona-Viren schon immer gibt und dass es jetzt nichts Neues ist. Oder dass es eben nur eine weitere Form der Grippe sein könnte. Also damit hängt das zusammen quasi.
Und kann man das sozusagen, und das geht jetzt vielleicht an Kattascha, weil du gesagt hast, von Verschwörungserzählungen als Hilfsmittel, oder doch Hilfsmittel vielleicht, um einen Kontrollverlust zu überleben, ist das sozusagen dann einfach eine eingängige Erklärung, mit der man sich selbst einfacher macht?
Ja, das muss man erstmal auch abwarten, wie wissenschaftliche Studien dazu sind. Aber intuitiv kann man natürlich erstmal mutmaßen, dass jemand, der glaubt, das Virus gibt es nicht, der hat einfach Angst vor anderen Dingen. Der hat dann vielleicht nicht Angst davor, dass er krank wird oder dass Angehörige krank werden, sondern hat dann, wenn er an andere Verschwörungserzählungen glauben sollte, was man dann ja in dem Einzelfall noch nicht weiß. Aber wenn er beispielsweise glaubt, eine globale Elite hat das dann irgendwie erfunden. Und das ist ja eigentlich gar nicht so, weil irgendwie muss man ja erklären, warum die Wissenschaft da zu einem anderen Ergebnis kommt. Dann hat er ja vielleicht Angst vor einer angeblichen, ja weiß ich nicht, Weltregierung, die das jetzt benutzt, um sich quasi an die Macht zu putschen. Das bedeutet allerdings auch, dass ich zumindest vor dem Virus erst mal keine Angst haben muss. Und gerade auch in der ganzen Klimadebatte gab es ja auch immer wieder Diskussionen, warum glauben Menschen nicht daran, dass es den menschengemachten Klimawandel gibt. Obwohl ja eigentlich gerade in den letzten Jahren auch die beobachtbaren Veränderungen einfach in vielen Ländern so unübersehbar sind. Das ist einfach sehr schwer zu leugnen, selbst wenn man sagt, ich glaube jetzt der eine Studie oder der andere Studie nicht. Und da ist eben ein Ansatz zu sagen, wenn ich eben nicht daran glaube, dass es den menschengemachten Klimawandel gibt, dann bedeutet das auch, ich brauche mir keine Vorwürfe zu machen, ich brauche mein Verhalten nicht zu ändern. Ja, und ich brauche erstmal keine Angst davor zu haben, dass wir auf eine globale Katastrophe zusteuern. Dann habe ich aber dafür andere Ängste, beispielsweise, dass ich dann denke, das ist irgendwie ein geheimer Plan, um die Wirtschaft zu strukturieren. Also es gibt es dann auch, dass beispielsweise behauptet wird, dahinter hängen nur grüne Unternehmen, wo man sich dann aber, wenn man sich mal die Kräfteverhältnisse anschaut, dann auch fragen muss, naja, wie realistisch ist das, dass die paar kleinen Solar- und Windkrafthersteller sich so gegen die globalen Erdölproduzenten da durchsetzen und da jetzt geheime Pläne entwickeln. So, erst mal fragt mich. Aber gerade bei diesen Erzählungen, wo es darum geht, es gibt Corona nicht, es ist ganz interessant, dass die, und das hatte Caro ja auch angesprochen, dass die ganz oft halt auch mit bestehenden Erzählungen zusammenhängen. Also da gab es ja auch so diese Erzählung, dass behauptet wurde, am 15. Mai werde quasi so in Deutschland geputscht. Also da gab es auch einzelne Akteure, die dann behauptet haben, so am nächsten Tag fahren bei uns die Panzer durch die Straßen quasi. Dann ist es vorbei mit der Demokratie, obwohl mit der Demokratie wäre es ja noch nie so weit gewesen und so weiter und so fort. Und dann ist ja, wenig erstaunlicherweise, auch nichts passiert. Aber die Überzeugung ist eben dann da, dass Corona so Teil einer größeren Geschichte ist. Und das wurde dann eben da so eingewebt. Und ja, man weiß halt im Zweifel nicht, wie auch die Genese der einzelnen Menschen ist, wie sie dazu kommen, daran zu glauben. Und das ist eben auch sehr unterschiedlich. Und das ist ja auch das Spannende bei diesen Demos. Also es stehen ja teilweise Leute nebeneinander, die einen sagen, es gibt das Virus nicht, und die anderen sagen, es gibt das Virus und es ist nur eine Grippe. Und die Dritten sagen, welches Virus? Das sind 5G-Strahlen. Und das ist eben auch die Sache, wo ich mir denke, das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass sich daraus irgendeine politische Bewegung bildet, weil die sind sich überhaupt nicht einig in vielen Dingen.
Dieses mit dem 5G, das möchte ich übrigens natürlich noch mal ein bisschen genauer erklären, weil das kriege ich gar nicht zusammen, was das miteinander zu tun hat. Also dass Mobilfunkstrahlung schädlich sein soll und dass man deswegen lieber ein Aluhut trägt, das habe ich schon gehört. Aber was genau hat das jetzt mit Corona zu tun? Ist das sozusagen, ist das so, wie du gerade gesagt hast? Die haben jetzt einfach zu sagen aufgegriffen, dieses neue Ding, das ist auch 5G und das war dann sozusagen ein Wohlfeil des weiteres Betätigungsfelds? Oder welche Verknüpfung gibt es da?
Na ja, es gab vorher schon Gruppen, die behauptet haben, dass 5G-Strahlung zur Gedankenkontrolle benutzt wird. Und dazu muss man wissen, davor gab es schon Gruppen, die dasselbe über LTE behauptet haben. Und davor gab es Gruppen, die das über 3G behauptet haben. Beim Radio gab es bestimmt auch entsprechende Gruppen. Man weiß es nicht, aber man kann schon sagen, das Thema Funkstrahlung ist halt für viele Menschen erstmal etwas, was sie anscheinend sehr zu irritieren scheint. Und es gibt gerade im esoterischen Bereich da eben Gruppen, die da ziemlich viel Angst vor haben, bis hin zu, dass sie dann eben an Verschwörungserzählungen glauben. Es gibt auch so einzelne sektenähnliche Gruppierungen oder so Gurus, die eigentlich auch eher so aus dem stark esoterischen Spektrum kommen, die dann aber auch sehr stark in diesem Milieu unterwegs sind. So Christina von Dreien ist da so eine sehr bekannte Figur. Diese Gruppen haben teilweise dann Corona in ihre Erzählung eingewoben, dass sie dann eben gesagt haben, naja, also in Wuhan, da gibt es schon 5G. Und der Grund, warum die Menschen dort krank werden, ist dann eben nicht ein Virus, sondern 5G. Wo man sich dann aber andererseits irgendwo fragen muss, naja, ich hätte gerne in Berlin 5G, ist leider nicht. Trotzdem werden hier Menschen offensichtlich krank. Und in anderen Ländern, wo es halt auch mit LTE nicht so weit ist, auch. Und da muss man halt wirklich sagen, also es spiegelt ja auch so ein bisschen, zeigt auch ganz gut so diese Glaubensfrage. Also es ist sehr schwierig, dann auch mit irgendwelchen Faktenchecks oder sowas durchzudrängen, weil die Menschen ja teilweise auch so weit in ihrem Glauben gefestigt sind, dass sie sagen, na ja, einen Faktenchecker, dem traue ich erst mal sowieso nicht, weil der ist ja Teil der Systempresse und die Systempresse ist wiederum Teil der großen Weltregierungen oder Weltverschwörungen, die es da so gibt. Und ja, also diese Gruppen, die gab es vorher schon. Und viele Menschen fragen, wo kommen die eigentlich her? Und meine Antwort wäre da, na ja, also viele von denen, die waren vorher schon so drauf. Sie sind halt nicht demonstrieren gegangen, sondern es gab dann diese YouTube-Channels. Aber wenn man da nicht zufällig mal auf den falschen Link klickt und in diese Filterblasen kommt, ja Filterblasen ist vielleicht das falsche Wort, aber in diese Milieus kommt, wo man dann feststellt, hoch, da hat ein Video mal eben eine Million Views, wo dann eben von Gedankenkontrolle und LTE gesprochen wird, oder 5G, dann merkt man das nicht. Weil es ja auch irgendwie nicht so nahe liegt.
Ich will mal kurz aufgreifen, was du gesagt hast und was gerade im IRC-Sendungs-Chat gesagt wurde, weil du gerade von kultähnlichen Zuständen auch sprachst. Und im IRC jemand gesagt hat, dass er glaubt, dass Religion oder sie die Menschen grundsätzlich bereiter macht, Verschwörungserzählungen zu glauben. Was ich mich manchmal gefragt habe, ist gerade auch in dem, was ihr jetzt hier erzählt, und interessanterweise sowohl, was die rechtsextremistische Desinformationen angeht, als auch Verschwörungserzählungen, dass ich das eigentlich glaube, man kann das zusammenfassen, das macht die Welt einfacher und es gibt immer die anderen, gegen die man sein kann. Und damit hat man sozusagen sehr viele klare Ziele. Und ich frag mich manchmal, ob es umgedreht ist. Früher gab es Religion im Leben, das heißt, man hatte sozusagen so ein fertig gebautes Konstrukt, was so ein bisschen übernatürlich war und mystisch und ritualer hatte. Und das gibt es heutzutage in unserer Welt nicht mehr. Und dass dieser Platz, also vielleicht brauchen wir als Menschen sozusagen so ein Ding, wo man nicht nachdenken muss, sondern wo man einfach dranhängen kann. Vielleicht ist da jetzt einfach so ein Vakuum. Und das wird jetzt gefüllt von eben diesen kultischen Verschwörungserzählungen. Habt ihr manchmal in euren Recherchen den Gedanken vielleicht im Kopf gehabt, vielleicht sind wir Menschen gar nicht dafür gemacht, dass das Leben so komplex ist. Und deswegen ist das sozusagen mehr oder weniger natürlich, dass es zu sowas kommt.
Ich glaube, es ist ein großer Trugschluss sein kann, zu sagen, das sind einfache Antworten. Also was einfach daran ist, es gibt klar definierte Feinde. Aber ganz viele von diesen Leuten, die wirklich tief drin sind in dieser Verschwörungsszene und viele von diesen Dingen glauben, beschäftigen sich teilweise stundenlang damit. Und teilweise kommen da wirklich komplexe Gebilde raus. Also es gab in den letzten Tagen zum Beispiel so ein Schaubild aus den USA, das so aus dem verschwörungsideologischen Spektrum kommt. Und eben wo es um Covid-19 als Bio-Waffe geht. Und dann aber auch die historischen Zusammenhänge klargemacht werden seit dem, ich glaube, ersten oder zweiten Weltkrieg. Und das Ding ist hochkomplex und ich habe es nicht verstanden beim ersten Angucken. Also ich glaube, das ist gar nicht so das Ding. Aber es gibt halt Antworten aktuell vor allem, wo noch keine sind und wo sich Antworten auch ändern. Das ist ja ein wichtiger Punkt. Wir reden ja auch seit Wochen darüber, inwiefern sich die Meinung von Virologen und auch Politikern zum Mund-Nasen-Schutz geändert hat zum Beispiel. Während halt die Antworten in diesem Verschwörungsspektrum ganz oft einfach klar sind, auch wenn sie sich teilweise ändern. Aber man ist komplett sicher. Und es gibt eben viele Unsicherheiten gerade. Und ich glaube, Sicherheit ist wichtiger als Komplexität.
Gerade im esoterischen Spektrum kann man schon sagen, dass so dieser Glaube daran, dass es hinter der vordergründigen Welt irgendwo eine mystische, eine versteckte Welt gibt. Es gibt irgendwo einen dahinter, hinter dem, was die Wissenschaft sagt. Ja, das ist schon anschlussfähig. Ich wäre aber vorsichtig zu sagen, dass es jetzt so eine Art Religionsersatz ist. Ich glaube tatsächlich nicht, dass Menschen Religion brauchen, um glücklich zu sein, so generell. Oder dass es da halt irgendwo eine Veranlagung gibt, dass wir das unbedingt brauchen. Und wenn es denn so wäre, dass es ein Religionsersatz wäre, dann müsste man ja sagen, naja, dann müssten die Leute im Mittelalter ja eigentlich total bedient gewesen sein. Also hoch religiös. Ja, man hat wirklich alles versucht, mit Religion und Gott zu erklären. Die Kirche hatte eine unglaubliche Machtposition. Und trotzdem ist es eben zu Pogromen gegen jüdische Communities gekommen, weil dann während der Pestepidemie behauptet wurde, ja, also die vergiften jetzt die Brunnen. Also so Klassiker jüdische Weltverschwörung. Und ich finde es auch schwierig, dass immer wieder gesagt wird so, ja, unser Leben ist heute so komplex. Ich würde das erst mal bezweifeln, dass das Leben heute komplexer ist als das Leben eines einfachen Bauern im Mittelalter oder jemanden, der halt in der Stadt lebt im Mittelalter meint wegen. Das ist eine andere Komplexität. Und wir stellen uns das immer so einfach vor, wo man sich sagen muss, naja, also heute haben wir beispielsweise ganz viele Institutionen und soziale Absicherungen und so etwas. Also in gewisser Weise ist mein Leben in einigen Bereichen viel einfacher, als es im Mittelalter gewesen wäre. Ich brauche keine Angst vor vielen Krankheiten zu haben. Ja, ich werde halt viel, viel älter, nicht nur 30 oder so. Und bin mit 30 eine alte Frau, sondern ich werde wahrscheinlich 80, 90 werden, hopefully. Und die Komplexität hat sich geändert. Und man kann schon sagen, von Studien zum Thema Glaube an Verschwörungen und Verbreitungen in der Bevölkerung, dass das Internet da jetzt nicht erkennbar so eine große Veränderung gebracht hätte. Also gerade so in den letzten Jahren, so in Deutschland, da gibt es regelmäßige Untersuchungen, wie beispielsweise die Mittelstudien, die hauptsächlich Rechtsextremismus in der Bevölkerung erfassen. Aber es gibt da einzelne Fragen, die auch zum Glauben an Verschwörungen, aber das halt eben auch abfragen. Und da kann man schon sagen, da hat sich jetzt eigentlich nicht so viel geändert in den letzten Jahren, wobei gleichzeitig in den letzten Jahren die Internetnutzung doch sehr stark zugenommen hat in einigen Gruppen. Natürlich verändert sich die Art und Weise, wie Verschwörungserzählungen entstehen oder auch weiterverbreitet werden, stark durch das Internet. Also ja, früher Mund-zu-Mund-Propaganda oder gibt es einzelne Autoren oder vielleicht eine UFO-Zeitschrift, die man abonniert. Ja, und jetzt, das hat Caro ja auch beschrieben, QAnon-Gruppen, wo dann quasi so eine kollektive, weltweite, globale Erzählung gemacht wird, die sich auch innerhalb von Stunden ändern kann.
Und denen aber trotzdem noch nach wie vor die Protokolle der Weisen von Zion verbreitet werden. Also der Klassiker ist immer noch da. Und das war vor dem Internet, ne?
Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen verwirrt, weil das klang jetzt ja nach, eigentlich hat sich nichts geändert, aber eigentlich hat sich doch alles geändert. Und ich fühl mich auch ein bisschen missverstanden, weil natürlich ist unser Leben sozusagen besser im technischen Sinne. Und es ist auch klar, dass sozusagen, egal wie es dem Menschen geht, er hat immer sozusagen anscheinend dieselbe Anzahl an Problemen, also von wegen Komplexität in seinem eigenen Lebens. Aber ich, also wie soll ich das sagen? Ich meinte auch sozusagen nicht Religion als Mittel der Glückseligkeit, sondern Religion oder sozusagen mystische Erzählungen als Mittel zur Komplexitätsreduktion des eigenen Lebens. Und da frage ich mich schon, ob wir heute nicht in einer anderen Zeit leben, weil man hat sozusagen, also früher hatte man halt die Wahl, glaubst du der Kirche oder deinem Adligen oder den geraunten Geschichten auf dem Dorfplatz. Und heute gibt es auch etwas, das klingt erst mal sehr einfach, nämlich wir haben so viel Wissen an der Hand, wir können im Prinzip die Wahrheit für alles rausfinden. Aber das stimmt eben nicht. Sondern es gibt da draußen ganz viele Wahrheiten. Und das meinte ich damit sozusagen. Dann ist es vielleicht einfacher, sich so einer Verschwörungserzählung anzuhängen.
Nee, es gibt ja vor allem auch ein massives Angebot an Informationen. Das, glaube ich, schon ein Teil ist. Also es gibt ja diese aktuellen Erhebungen auch zur Einstellung, zu Impfungen und so weiter, während der Corona-Krise. Und man sieht schon zum Beispiel da ja teilweise, dass so ein bisschen der Trend zur Informationsvermeidung geht. Weil es eben teilweise zu negativ ist, aber auch weil es eben so ein massives Angebot ist. Und es teilweise schwer ist zu filtern. Also ich kenne das aus meinem Umfeld, das ja auch zum Glück auch aus Nicht-Journalisten besteht. Dass es da natürlich einen ganz anderen Zugang zu Informationen und Nachrichten gibt. Weil die Zeit eine ganz andere ist, wenn man sehr, sehr unterschiedlich mit Freizeit- und Freizeiteinteilung umgeht. Und da ist das schon ein Faktor. Das nehme ich aus meinem Umfeld auf jeden Fall wahr. Aber das ist eben auch anecdotisch aktuell.
Ich würde gerne für die aktuellen Verschwörungserzählungen noch zu einer Auswirkung kommen, von der ich nicht genau weiß, ob es die wirklich gibt oder ob das nur eine Beobachtung ist. Es gab am Rand von so Hygienedemos ein paar Berichte von Gewalt gegen Journalisten. Da gab es dann einen kleinen Aufschrei, der war unter Kolleginnen. Das ist jetzt eine neue Qualität der Gewalt am Rande, die der Verschwörer nehmen muss. Wir hatten auch bei Breitband ein Interview mit Simone Raphael, die meinte, zynisch gesehen kann man sagen, das ist eigentlich nichts Besonderes. Aber im Sinne von auf Demonstrationen, wo Rechtsextreme sind, findet auch Gewalt gegen Donalismus statt. Aber gibt es da einen Zusammenhang zwischen Verschwörungserzählung und Gewaltbereitschaft, der sich jetzt vielleicht auch ändert? Also sind Menschen, die einer Verschwörungserzählung glauben, ihr bereit, diese auch mit Gewalt zu verteidigen?
Ich glaube, diese Gewaltneigungsfrage würde ich gleich noch an dich weitergeben, Kata, aber ich würde kurz antworten auf diese Journalismusfrage und auch die Angriffe. Also erstmal muss man im Einzelfall schauen, was auch die Ermittlungen ergeben noch. Dieser Angriff auf das Heutesshow-Team, das fand ich schon ziemlich erschreckend, weil es so ein massiver Angriff von einer größeren Gruppe wohl war, die eben ein Team, das gerade überhaupt nicht gefilmt hat, angegriffen hat. Das fand ich schon ziemlich heftig. Andere Sachen, die wir gesehen haben, fand ich tatsächlich auch wenig überraschend. Und ich hab vorher in Leipzig gewohnt, sehr, sehr lange. Und Pegida und Legida sitzen mir eigentlich heute noch in den Knochen. Also ich kenn eigentlich kaum jemanden, der von den Demos berichtet hat, der nicht in irgendeiner Form zumindest verbal, aber teilweise auch ziemlich heftig körperlich angegangen wurde. Und insofern ist das, finde ich, nichts Neues. Was ich gesehen hab, also ich war auf einer der Demos und hab mir das angeschaut, am 1. Mai. Und also das war genau der Tag, an dem auch der Angriff auf das heute schon Team erfolgt ist, glaube ich. Und was ich beobachtet hab, war weniger Aggression gegenüber Journalisten. Das bin ich von Rechtsextremen Demos sehr, sehr viel mehr gewöhnt teilweise. Aber dafür sehr, sehr viele Einzelpersonen, die extrem aggressiv die Polizisten angeschrien haben. Dass ich so in der Form zum Beispiel wiederum nicht aus den Rechtsextremen Demos so massiv kenne. Da gab es teilweise schon noch ein paar Unterschiede, die ich wahrgenommen habe. Also grundsätzlich kann man aber auch sagen, sowohl aus diesen verschwörungsideologischen Demos, die ja auch teilweise Hooligans und sonstige angezogen haben in verschiedenen Teilen Deutschlands, als auch von Pegida und Co. Ist man tatsächlich inzwischen mehr oder minder gewöhnt, dass man mit einem Kamerateam auch inzwischen mit Sicherheitsleuten unterwegs ist. Das ist leider nicht ganz so neu.
Ja, also ich muss dazu sagen, ich hatte auch eine Medienanfrage. Da hieß es so, ja, haben Sie Lust vor Ort, die Demo mit einem Kamerateam zu kommentieren? Wir haben auch Sicherheitsleute dabei. Und da habe ich direkt gesagt, so nee, sorry. Also abseits davon, dass wir gerade eine Pandemie haben und dass mir eine Massenveranstaltung jetzt nicht so verlockend erscheint. Ja, mit dem Kamerateam.
Holy shit, liebe Kollegen, was zur Hölle.
Ja, ich hatte die gleiche. Ich habe sie auch abgesagt und finde sie auch schwierig.
Ja, vor allem gerade, wenn man eh schon so aus diesem Milieu halt so diverse Fanposts bekommt mit diversen verbalen Ausschmückungen, wie unser erstes Date aussehen könnte. Um es mal vorsichtig zu formulieren, hat man da jetzt nicht so unbedingt Bock drauf. Also ich kann aber auch verstehen, dass man natürlich auch vor Ort berichten will. Aber als Expertin möchte ich dann nicht unbedingt in Kombination mit einem Filmteam dann quasi mir, hallo, hier bin ich, so groß auf die Brust schreiben, ist mir dann doch ein bisschen zu heikel. Aber ich würde ja auch Caros Einschätzung eigentlich teilen. Also das, was wir im Bereich Rechtsextremismus beobachten, da braucht man jetzt auch nicht nur die Demos anzuschauen, das ist ja nur ein Teil der Geschichte. Es gibt ziemlich viele Autoren, die über die neue Rechte schreiben, kritisch schreiben. Oder vor allem Leute, die auch gar nicht so in der bundesweiten Presse aktiv sind, sondern eher Lokaljournalismus machen, die dann wirklich umziehen müssen, die vor Ort bedroht werden, vor deren Tür dann irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, Schweineblut oder so etwas deponiert wird, die dann auch von lokalen Gruppen systematisch angegriffen, eingeschüchtert werden. Und ja, also das ist eigentlich seit Jahren eine Sache, die sich immer mehr verschlimmert hat. Und ich finde es auch mittlerweile auch ehrlich gesagt ziemlich hart, wie stark auch viele Journalistinnen, aber auch Autorinnen und Autoren verinnerlicht haben, dass das zum Job dazugehört. Und ich finde, das schwingt auch so ein bisschen mit in dieser Debatte, die wir jetzt hatten, um diese Drohbriefe, die zugesendet wurden an Christian Drosten und auch an andere, wo dann Herr Till Schweiger gesagt hat, naja, also nach dem Motto hier ist es doch nicht so dramatisch oder so, er hat sich hinterher dafür entschuldigt. Aber das zeigt eben auch so einen gewissen Zeitgeist, würde ich sagen, dass wir einfach dazu übergegangen sind, das für normal zu halten, also für unglaublich normal. Wenn ich mindestens zehn Morddrohungen in dem Bereich vorzuweisen und über Rechtsextremismus schreib, da denkt man auch so, ja, was hast du eigentlich falsch gemacht mittlerweile? Weil eigentlich ist das für normal. Es ist wirklich traurig, aber halt auch so Themen wie, was mache ich eigentlich mit dem Impressum in meinem Blog und so weiter, das ist ein Standardthema bei allen Leuten, die sich damit auseinandersetzen, weil du weißt, gerade wenn du in bestimmten Gegenden wohnst, sonst stehen die nächste Woche vor deiner Tür. Und wenn du Familie hast, hast du ein Problem.
Aber noch mal ab vom Rechtsextremismus, ist das auch etwas? Also Erzeugen, Verschwörungsmythen, Gewalt?
Also es gibt einen Zusammenhang, der da messbar war in Studien, dass man eben geschaut hat, wie ist die Gewaltbereitschaft. Und zumindest gerade im rechtsextremen Milieu wissen wir, dass ziemlich viele der Attentäter der letzten Jahre an Verschwörungserzählungen geglaubt haben. Beispielsweise an eine angebliche jüdische Weltverschwörung. Oder, also der Topseller der Rechtsextremisten ist ja so das Thema Umvolkung, Bevölkerungsaustausch. Und die haben damit ihre Taten legitimiert. Und ich meine klar, wenn ich meine Mitglieder, meine Anhänger so in dieses apokalyptische Weltbild ziehe, dass ich ihnen erkläre, wir stehen quasi an einem geschichtlichen Scheideweg. Ja, gibt es eine Elite? Politisch können wir halt eh nichts ändern, weil die Wahlen werden ja natürlich getürkt. Also sie werden gefälscht. Und alle Parteien stecken unter einer Decke. Die Medien auch. Die Medien sind Teil der Verschwörung. Die sind Feinde. Deshalb auch legitime Angriffstiere natürlich. Dann kann ich viel einfacher Gewalt legitimieren, weil ich da natürlich auch kommuniziere, sondern es gibt keinen anderen Weg. Weil die Medien sind Teil der Verschwörung. Ich brauch nicht mit der Presse zu reden. Die Politik ist Teil der Verschwörung. Da brauch ich gar nicht an Wahlen teilzunehmen. Und die Wahlergebnisse spiegeln dann ja auch angeblich nicht den wahren Willen der Bevölkerung wahr. Und die Repräsentanten, die da gewählt wurden, die haben keine Legitimität. Und natürlich kann ich damit in extremistischen Gruppen super Gewalt legitimieren. Das ist auf jeden Fall so.
Also es ist kein Automatismus. Also nicht jede Verschwörungserzählung führt automatisch zu Gewalt, aber kann dabei eine Rolle spielen. Ich würde gleich noch mal ein bisschen reden, obwohl Katta gerade gesagt hatte, das Internet hat nicht so viel Unterschied gemacht, würde ich trotzdem noch mal über die Rolle von Plattformen sprechen. Also wie da diese Dinge verteilt werden, welche Rolle sie da spielen und vielleicht auch, was die Verantwortung der Plattform da selber sein kann. Vorher hören wir aber noch eine kleine Musik von unserem De-Sendunging-Album Since Working overtime und zwar Double Jump und sind dann gleich wieder da. Das ist ein Double Jump vom Album Since Working Overtime von Lee Rosseweir. Hier beim Chaosradio 260, wo wir über Verschwörungserzählungen oder Lügen, die die Gesellschaft radikalisieren, sprechen. Wir haben schon ganz viel darüber gesprochen, welche das sind, wo die herkommen. Nicht, das machen wir jetzt. Welche das sind und was für Auswirkungen sie haben können. Und wo sie herkommen, doch zumindest inhaltlich schon. Aber ich würde jetzt tatsächlich nochmal die Informationsinfrastruktur, die Verschwörungserzählungen nutzen, besprechen wollen. Und da ist natürlich Hygienedemos quasi das Ende der Verbreitung, könnte man sagen. Welche Rolle spielen digitale, interaktive, soziale Medien? Vor allen Dingen Telegram. Wenn man das nur aus einem Auge verfolgt, ist das immer mal wieder vorgekommen. Telegram, ein Messenger, der sich als sicher ausgibt, aber bestenfalls als fragwürdig bezeichnet werden kann, aber der irgendwie einen Hort anscheinend für VerschwörungserzählerInnen ist. Warum?
Telegram gehört zu diesen sogenannten All-Tag-Plattformen in gewisser Weise. Einfach aus dem Grund, weil es den Ruf hat, eher sicher zu sein, was eher die Lüge ist, ehrlich gesagt. Und andererseits aber auch, weil es den Ruf hat, wenig zu moderieren oder gar nicht zu moderieren. Aus dem Grund haben sich vor ein paar Jahren Islamisten zusammengefunden. Es gab jahrelange ES-Kanäle, auf denen auch Rekrutierung stattgefunden hat. 2016, 2017, 2018 sind so die Rechtsextremen nachgerückt. Diese Entwicklung gab es auch in Deutschland. Das heißt, es ist nicht so, dass das jetzt seit Anfang Februar erst passiert ist, dass man sich dort quasi niedergelassen hat und seinen alternativen Kanal angelegt hat, sondern Martin Sellner zum Beispiel hat schon 2017 seinen ersten Telegram-Kanal angelegt und reichlich beworben, also zum Beispiel auch auf YouTube. Aktuell ist es so, dass man sieht, dass ziemlich viel auf Telegram passiert, dass es dort auch teilweise massiven Zuwachs gibt in verschwörungsideologischen und oder rechtsradikalen Kreisen. Und ich hab mir das jetzt über Wochen genauer angeguckt und meine These hat sich so ein bisschen bestätigt. Also es ist zum Beispiel nicht so, dass alle Akteure aus der rechtsradikalen Szene Zuwachs bekommen haben und da massiv Leute für sich gewonnen haben, sondern es sind tatsächlich die, die auch Verschwörungsideologien verbreiten. Und wir haben dankenswerterweise heute die meiste Zeit auf diese Namen verzichtet. Und ich glaube, ich sag sie jetzt auch nur einmal, aber Leute wie Xavier Naidoo und auch Attila Hildman haben dort relativ massiv und sehr schnell Zuwachs gewonnen, aber sind auch teilweise durch eben Menschen stark gepusht worden, die da schon lange im Verschwörungsideologischen Spektrum aktiv waren. Und auch die haben da teilweise zehntausende Leute dazugewonnen, die ihre Kanäle auf Telegram abonniert haben. Also es ist schon beeindruckend, wenn man das in dem Kontext sagen kann.
So viel zu Telegram und was für oder spielen andere Plattformen auch eine Rolle? Du hast jetzt YouTube gerade erwähnt bei dem einen Protagonisten. Spielen die eine besondere Rolle bei der Verbreitung von Verschwörungserzählungen und Mythen? Oder werden die dafür benutzt wie für alles andere auch?
Also Verschwörungserzählungen und Mythen sind ähnlich wie Falschmeldungen, auch nur dann wirklich erfolgreich, wenn sie überall stattfinden. Und das ist tatsächlich so. Also es gibt eben auch reichlich Zeugs auf allen anderen Kanälen. Das heißt, es gibt Organisationen für die Demos auf Facebook, in Facebook Gruppen zum Beispiel. Es gibt reichlich Kram auf Twitter, gerade unter Medienartikeln. Es gibt unglaublich viel auf YouTube, muss man sagen. Also YouTube ist zentral für die Verschwörungserzählungen, die wir gerade sehen. Und da passiert auch teilweise relativ wenig. Dafür gibt es aber auch wiederum eine Strategie, die dann wieder auf Telegram zurückgreift. Das heißt, wenn größere Kanäle, wie zum Beispiel der von Oliver Janich, ein Video auf YouTube veröffentlicht haben und das wird dann gelöscht, dann gibt es eben die Strategie, dass man es nochmal auf Telegram hochlädt und die Gefolgschaft jeweils dazu aufruft, das auf ihren eigenen Kanälen auf YouTube hochzuladen. Also auch da gibt es auch eine Wechselwirkung zwischen den Kanälen. Das heißt, im Prinzip ist es überall. Wir sehen es auch auf TikTok inzwischen, dass da reichlich Verschwörungsmythen unterwegs sind. WhatsApp spielt eine Rolle. Da gab es ja ganz zu Anfang diese Sprachnachrichten, an die sich jetzt schon keiner mehr so richtig erinnern kann, weil es gefühlt drei Jahre her ist. Aber eigentlich war es erst im März, dass da die verschiedensten Dinge per Sprachnachricht auf WhatsApp zum Beispiel verbreitet wurden. Also im Prinzip gibt es keine Plattform, auf der alles irgendwie nett und verschwörungsfrei ist.
Seht ihr die Plattformen da in der Pflicht, was dagegen zu unternehmen? Und vielleicht wird die Frage sogar noch ein bisschen weiter. Verschwörungserzählungen sind ja schlecht greifbar, weil vom Inhalt her sind sie ja einfach Quatsch. Es sind ja die Auswirkungen, die so dramatisch sind. Glaubt ihr trotzdem an...
Ja, das ist immer, finde ich, ein sehr schwieriges Thema, weil gerade bei Interviews in den letzten Wochen habe ich dann auch immer so rausgehört quasi, na ja, soll man das jetzt alles löschen, soll man das jetzt alles zensieren, soll man da stärker durchgreifen? Und ich muss sagen, ich finde, das ist eine ganz, ganz schwierige Frage. Denn wenn wir mal global betrachten, also nicht nur Deutschland anschauen, sondern auch andere Länder, da muss man ja sagen, wenn wir jetzt sagen würden, alles, was eine Verschwörungserzählung ist, das soll automatisch gelöscht werden, dann wären natürlich diverse Regierungen dazu übergehen, sehr merkwürdige Dinge als Verschwörungserzählungen zu definieren. Ja, beispielsweise alles, was die Opposition verbreitet. Und dann haben wir eben eine sehr, sehr, sehr schwierige Debatte plötzlich. Gleichwohl muss man natürlich aber sagen, dass diese Plattformen ja nicht nur so funktionieren, dass Leute was reinstellen und dann, weiß ich nicht, suchen sie gezielt nach etwas und stoßen da drauf, sondern wir wissen eben auch aus Untersuchungen der letzten Jahre, dass diese Vorschlagsalgorithmen bei YouTube schon eine Radikalisierungstendenz hatten. Das ging so weit, dass YouTube selbst irgendwann eingeräumt hat, ja, es gibt ein Problem. Weil man hatte nämlich festgestellt, dass Menschen, die Verschwörungserzählungsvideos schauen, dass das sehr treue Kunden sind sozusagen. Also ein sehr treuer Zuschauer. Und wenn ich jetzt in einer KI sage, maximiere mal die insgesamt Zuschauerzahl. Weil man muss ja, also je länger Leute zuschauen, desto höher sind ja vielleicht auch die Werbeeinnahmen, die ich damit generieren kann. Dann schlage ich eher Videos vor, wo sie dranbleiben. Und wenn eben Verschwörungserzählungen da halt diesen Effekt ganz stark, ganz eindeutig bringen, dann wird das eben mehr vorgeschlagen. Und da hat YouTube auch selbst irgendwann festgestellt, okay, die KI ist da so ein bisschen amok gelaufen. Wir müssen das jetzt zurückfragen.
Aha, also doch, die KI.
Genau, die KI ist schuld. Aber so einfach ist es eben nicht. Weil man muss ja sagen, warum hat die KI das festgestellt? Der Grund liegt natürlich auch in unserer Psyche irgendwo. Dass wir natürlich für solche Dinge grundsätzlich schon vor dem Netz anfällig waren. Und natürlich auch, dass wir auch dazu tendieren, Sachen, die besonders reißerisch sind oder halt irgendwie so aufregend oder hier wird eine Wahrheit enthüllt. Das finden wir natürlich halt auch erstmal spannend. Und man hat ja auch diesen Effekt, dass wenn du Menschen glaubhaft machst, die Medien lügen alle, dann ist natürlich die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass jemand mehr YouTube guckt, ja auch irgendwo größer. Und man muss halt einfach schon sagen, dass diese Vorschlagsalgorithmen da schon eine Rolle spielen. Also gerade auch bei Facebook haben wir so ein Experiment im Rahmen unserer Buchrecherche gemacht und dann war es schon sehr offensichtlich, wenn ich so ein paar UFO-Gruppen beitrete, irgendwie weiß ich nicht, Hitler lebt in der Arktis, Hohelerde, was es da so gibt, dann werden einem sehr schnell andere Gruppen vorgestarkend, die halt so in dieses selbe Milieu gehen. Und da ist eben die große Frage, was für eine Rolle spielt das ja und wie kann man das gut lösen, dass das nicht mehr so stark stattfindet, weil ich würde auch nicht sagen, dass die Plattformen das jetzt unbedingt beabsichtigt haben. Ganz im Gegenteil, es ist halt unglaublich schlechte Presse so in dem Zusammenhang auch. Das möchte man eigentlich nicht. Man wollte einfach nur die Interaktionszeit maximieren. Und das hat eben so gewisse Side-Effects gehabt, die ziemlich hässlich sind. Und diese Side-Effects gibt es eben auch in anderen Bereichen, wenn wir uns angucken, wie beispielsweise bestimmte Nachrichten, die sehr reißerisch sind, die sehr emotional sind, wie die halt automatisch gepusht werden, weil sie eben viele Klicks verursachen. Da muss man sich halt auch fragen, wie wirkt das auf unsere Gesellschaft? Und ich finde, an der Stelle müssen wir ganz eindeutig diskutieren. Ich meine, zum Faktencheck kann ja Caro sicher noch mehr erzählen. Da sehe ich eindeutig Verbesserungsbedarf. Also jetzt ist es bei YouTube unter Videos zum Thema Chemtrails. Dann ist da halt unten so ein Link. Also Chemtrails ist eine Verschwörungserzählung, wo es dann eben heißt, die Bevölkerung will, die Regierung will uns irgendwie kontrollieren, dadurch, dass sie Gift versprüht. Und zwar in jedem Flugzeug, das über uns fliegt. Und deshalb sehen wir da so Streifen. Das glauben tatsächlich Menschen. Und da ist dann so ein Wikipedia-Link, wo ich mir denke, so ein Wikipedia-Link konkurriert ja nicht so gleichwertig zu einem super gut aufgemotzten Video.
Ich muss kurz was einschieben, weil das immer wieder bei mir aufblinkt, wenn wir drüber sprechen. Und zwar, ich entschuldige mich, das ist ein bisschen albern, aber wenn also die Flugzeuge dazu dienen, uns zu vergiften, aber wegen der Corona-Krise, das es ja nicht gibt, die Flugzeuge nicht mehr fliegen, dann passt das ja alles nicht zusammen. Ach so, deswegen muss man nicht mehr fliegen. Das ist quasi der Effizient. Das sind die effizienteren Chemtrails. Aber dieser Widerspruch finde ich ganz interessant. Also gerade weil es ja auch so ist, es gab das Reichsbürgertum, also es gibt keine BRD, das ist eine GmbH, das ist alles Quatsch. Sind das aber dann auch dieselben Leute, die jetzt das Grundgesetz verteidigen, also meinen zu verteidigen, die Maskenpflicht und das Versammlungskontaktverbot? Das heißt, wenn man Verschwörungstheorien glaubt, glaubt man wirklich alles, weil man sie alles irgendwie zurechtbiegt? Oder sind das verschiedene? Also sind die Chemtrail-Gläubige immer ganz disjunkt von der Menge her miteinander?
Also interessanterweise gibt es eine Reihe von Studien, die geschaut hat, was ist denn ein Indikator dafür, dass jemand an Verschwörungserzählungen glaubt. Und die haben dann eben festgestellt, naja, so ein sehr starker Indikator ist eben, dass jemand an schon eine andere Verschwörungserzählung glaubt. Und da gab es eine britische Studie, die hat beispielsweise untersucht, Verschwörungserzählungen zum Thema Tod von Prinzessin Diana. Die ist ja bei einem Autounfall gestorben, verursacht dadurch, dass sie von Paparazzis verfolgt wurde. Und da gibt es eben so Verschwörungserzählungen, wo es heißt, naja, das war der Geheimdienst, wahlweise der britische oder der israelische oder aber da steckt die Königsfamilie dahinter und dann gibt es noch die Verschwörungserzählung, eigentlich lebt sie. Und in dieser Studie konnte festgestellt werden, dass Menschen, die glauben, so der Tod, das war halt auf jeden Fall ein Komplott, die glauben eher auch gleichzeitig, dass sie noch lebt. Also die glauben teilweise Dinge, die sich gegenseitig widersprechen. Und jetzt fragt man sich natürlich, wie kann das sein? Na ja, aber der gemeinsame Nenner ist eben von diesen beiden Versionen, sag ich mal, dass man eben glaubt, die offizielle Geschichte, die stimmt nicht. Und das ist, würde ich sagen, das Hauptnarrativ, was dann da drüber steht, was auch dafür sorgt, dass man auch unterschiedliche Dinge, die sich gegenseitig ausschließen, dann glaubt. Es gab ja auch zum Thema Antisemitismus in Deutschland zur Nazizeit gab es ja auch sehr interessante Phänomene, dass gleichzeitig behauptet wurde, ja, es gibt eine jüdische Weltverschwörung, das ist eine kapitalistische Weltverschwörung und das sind halt so, nach dem Motto, das sind die Banker, das sind die Reichen. Und dann gleichzeitig gab es aber diese Verschwörungserzählung von der bolschewistisch-jüdischen Weltverschwörung, was sich ja irgendwo widersprechen sollte. Aber es war irgendwie kein Problem, diesen Widerspruch auszuhalten, weil man eben dann so ein übergeordnetes Narrativ hatte und dem hat man das dann eben untergeordnet.
Wahnsinn.
Ich glaube aber auch diese kognitive Dissonanz, das muss auch gar nicht so sehr überraschen, ehrlich gesagt. Also es gibt zum Beispiel ja auch in unterrechtsradikalen gleichzeitig die Ansicht, dass Migranten kommen, um Arbeitsplätze wegzunehmen, aber auch kommen, um sich vom Staat aushalten zu lassen. Also beide existieren in der gleichen Szene gleichzeitig und werden auf die gleiche Gruppe angewendet. Das ist nicht ganz neu.
Manchmal frage ich mich doch, ob meine Welt nicht einfacher wäre, wenn ich das auch einfach alles glauben könnte.
Dann könntest du 5G nicht benutzen. Das wäre nicht gut.
Okay, das stimmt. Schnelles Internet ist wichtiger.
Kann ich noch kurz zu den Plattformen?
Ja, da wollte ich eh geradezu hin zurück.
Also ich glaube auch, wie Katha schon sagte, dass es nicht unbedingt in jedem Fall absicht war. Aber was man sagen kann, ist, dass es ausreichend Hinweise gibt inzwischen, dass es zumindest teilweise schon vor Jahren erkannt wurde und man sich entschieden hat, eher nichts dagegen zu machen. Und das ist halt ein Teil des Problems. Gleichzeitig muss man sagen, dass auch Verschwörungsmythen gesamtgesellschaftlich relativ lange belächelt wurden. Und dass es gerade eigentlich etwas ist, was nicht nur die Plattform aushandeln müssen, sondern wir auch gesamtgesellschaftlich und Politik und Medien und alle sind beteiligt. Und ich glaube, da kommen wir auch noch mal darauf zu. Aber tatsächlich sehe ich gerade viele Parallelen zu der Diskussion um terroristische Inhalte zum Beispiel. Weil es eben genau da auch das, was Katha schon gerade angesprochen hat, diese Diskussion schon darum gab, welcher Staat bezeichnet was als Terrorismus. Wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel zwischen Deutschland und der Türkei vergleichen. Und auch da sind wir eigentlich noch nicht weit genug in der Diskussion und fangen jetzt tatsächlich schon mit der Nächsten an und führen sie alle leider gleichzeitig.
Aber ich würde jetzt gerne noch zwei Sachen zu Plattformen fragen. Das eine ist, es gibt ja dieses Begriff oder dieses Konzept der Filterblase, die aber mittlerweile verschieden bewertet wird. Weil Filterblase, das eine war so ein bisschen, man rutscht da in sowas rein und dann nimmt man diese neue Meinung erst an, weil sie eben in der Filterblase präsentiert wird. Und die andere, die also für meine Wahrnehmung zumindest in der theoretischen Diskussion jetzt langsam immer mehr an Gewicht gewinnt ist, dass sie sagt, also eine Einstellungsänderung findet durch Filterblasen nicht statt. Sondern es ist einfach nur, du siehst halt mehr vom selben, aber das ist halt einfach so. Wie seht ihr das? Gibt es Filterblasen? Und wenn ja, schaffen sie Verschwörungserzählungsglauben? Oder sind sie einfach nur sozusagen das Gefäß, wo man reinrutscht, weil man sich eh dafür interessiert, sag ich mal?
Also es gibt ja inzwischen relativ reichlich Angebote aus der Welt der Studien zum Thema Filterblasen. Und der Großteil sagt ja eigentlich inzwischen, dass es gar nicht so den starken Effekt hat. Also dass man teilweise mehr Informationen zum gleichen Thema oder aus dem gleichen Spektrum erhält, aber gleichzeitig noch andere Dinge wahrnimmt. Und das ist ja bei der Mehrheit, der Facebook nutzt, tatsächlich zum Beispiel auch so, dass man eben nicht das total homogene Feld von Freunden hat. Und da auch noch reichlich andere Informationen reinkommen. Die Frage ist dann vielleicht eher, welche Informationen sind dominanter und welche verbleiben oder verfangen auch mehr. Und da kommen wir wieder auf die Emotionalisierung zurück, die da eine Rolle spielt. Und gleichzeitig würde ich aber sagen, Telegram zum Beispiel ist eigentlich relativ abgeschlossen. Wenn man da in einer politischen Ecke unterwegs ist, dann bleibt man da auch und gerät jetzt nicht durch Zufall noch in irgendwelche anderen Spektren rein. Also es gibt die Möglichkeit, dass man auf andere Kanäle stößt, weil halt viele Kanäle und Gruppen untereinander sich teilen und dadurch auch Reichweite verschaffen gegenseitig. Aber das sind eben auch Leute, die wirklich alle zum gleichen Spektrum gehören. Und Gegenrede findet eigentlich überhaupt nicht mehr statt.
Kata, hast du da auch noch einen Take oder?
Ja, also das mit den Filterblasen ist halt so eine Sache. Also wir hatten, also Karo hat es ja schon sehr treffend zusammengefasst. Also es ist ja auch nicht so, dass wir im analogen Leben jetzt total Bock hätten, jedes Wochenende mit, also ich jedenfalls nicht, mit AfD-Wählern Bier trinken zu gehen und danach gehen wir auf eine Techno-Party. Wir machen die Nacht durch, weil es so lustig ist mit Heinrich. Also so sind die Menschen halt nicht. Man sucht sich ja seine Freunde oder sein Bezugsumfeld ja eher so wie man auch ähnlich selbst tickt. Und das führt dann auch dazu, dass meistens die anstrengenden Diskussionen dann oft im Familienkreis, so im politischen Bereich stattfinden. Weil im Privaten kann man sich ja schon aussuchen, ein bisschen mit wem man seine Zeit verbringt und mit wem nicht. Und manchmal spart man dann auch vielleicht ganz bewusst das Thema Politik aus. Es ist schon so, dass man sich natürlich selber auch sucht, in welche Gruppen man da reinrutscht. Ich würde aber schon sagen, dass so dieses, ja dieser Vorschlagsalgorithmus oder was wird besonders stark in die Timeline gepusht, dass das einen Effekt hat. Wie stark dieser Effekt ist, ist natürlich sehr unterschiedlich. Davon, über welche Plattform wir sprechen, ist natürlich unterschiedlich. Davon auch, über was familiar ist. Wir sprechen aber gerade, wenn wir über YouTube sprechen, würde ich schon sagen, dass das einen Einfluss darauf hat, wie schnell Leute mit Dingen in Kontakt kommen und wie schnell man von einem auf das andere kommt. Also wir haben im Rahmen unserer Recherche uns dann halt auch so Videos angeguckt und dann halt einfach konsequent geguckt, naja, was wird uns denn danach vorgeschlagen? Und dann konnte man wirklich sehen, ausgehend von einem Verschwörungsvideo über 5G gab es dann verschiedene Entscheidungswege. Der eine führte zu so religiösen Gruppen, wo man dann am Ende bei so der großen satanistischen Verschwörung irgendwie gelandet ist, wo dann angeblich irgendwie Angela Merkel mit irgendwelchen anderen Politikern irgendwie Satan anbetet. Vereinfacht gesagt, ein anderer Pfad führte dann zu dieser Erzählung von Exenmenschen, außerirdischen Exenmenschen, die die Welt regieren. Und da konnte man dann eben hinkommen, indem man halt einfach so guckt, was wird einem empfohlen. Wenn man dann zwei, drei Videos aus diesem Spektrum dann angeschaut hat, dann haben sich die Empfehlungen schon angepasst und das war früher eben deutlich stärker als heute. Ich würde aber schon sagen, dass das eine Rolle spielt.
In der Rolle wobei? In der Rolle dabei, Leute da reinzuziehen oder da drin zu halten?
Es ist ja schon eine bewusste Entscheidung, ob ich sage, ich gucke mir das an oder nicht. Ich finde, manchmal die Gefahr an diesen Filterblasen-Diskussionen ist, dass die ja auch ein bisschen die Verantwortung von Menschen rausnimmt und sagt, die sind jetzt alle rechtsextrem geworden, weil der YouTube-Algorithmus halt irgendwie doof ist. So ist es natürlich nicht. Da spielen natürlich auch menschliche Faktoren eine Rolle. Es kann aber ein Verstärker sein in bestimmten Situationen. So würde ich es halt eher sehen. Es ist halt ein Faktor von vielen. Also ein Beispiel, die Vorträgung spielt ja auch eine ganz bestimmte Rolle. Also ich gehe ja nicht, ich werde ja nicht neu geboren quasi. Als Kleinkind gehe ich auf YouTube und dann spielt sich mein politisches Leben auf YouTube ab, sondern ich bin ja vorgeprägt durch Schule, durch Medien, durch Freunde, durch Familie. Und die prägen auch mein Bild darüber, wie ich beispielsweise Medien wahrnehme, wie ich Wissenschaft wahrnehme. Und das spielt eine Rolle dafür, wie ich eben auch auf solche Verschwörungs-Sachen reagiere. Da würde ich sagen, ein Faktor von vielen, aber nicht überbedet.
Genau, ich würde gleich sozusagen dazu kommen, wie wir als Gesellschaft, aber auch privat damit umgehen. Ich habe noch zu den Plattformen oder den sozialen Medien noch eine Frage und zwar ist die, was ja immer wieder als Argument kommt für die Verbreitung von Verschwörungserzählungen ist, guck mal dieses Video, das hat ja eine Million Leute gesehen. Und ich frage mich, ob nicht das vielleicht ein größeres Gewicht hat, als es eigentlich sinnvoll wäre. Weil, dass da eine Million steht, das heißt ja erstmal überhaupt nichts, außer dass diese URL eine Million mal aufgerufen wurde. Ist das vielleicht gar nicht so klug, nur weil Dinge eine hohe Zahl haben in einer sozialen Plattform, die anzunehmen, als die es weit verbreitet? Also gibt man ihnen da vielleicht mehr Relevanz, als es sein müsste?
Na ja, es gibt schon Untersuchungen und Umfragen, die beispielsweise ermittelt haben, wie viele Menschen glauben, dass die US-Regierung heimlich Kontakt mit Aliens hatte und das der Bevölkerung verschweigt? Oder wie viele Menschen glauben an Chemtrails? Oder wie viele Menschen glauben daran, dass AIDS eigentlich in einem Labor entwickelt wurde und quasi ein Biokampfstoff ist? Und je nach Verschwörungserzählung kommt man dann schon auf Werte von um die 10%. Also Beispiel AIDS oder Ebola, diese These, dass es von irgendwelchen Regierungen entwickelt worden sei, das ist in unterschiedlichen Ländern schon relativ stark verbreitet, 10-20%. Da kommt man schon je nach Land drauf. Und von daher halte ich das schon für realistisch, dass zumindest ein Anteil der Menschen, die das schauen, das auch ernst meint. Also klar gibt es die Leute, die dann halt irgendwie beim Mittagessen sich langweilen und sich dann denken, ja geil wieder eine Verschwörungsdoku so zur Abendunterhaltung. Klar gibt es auch. Aber es gibt eben diese Umfragen, die zeigen, es gibt mehr Leute als man denkt, die daran glauben.
Meintest du nicht eben eher, dass sich Glaubwürdigkeit aus den Klickzahlen ergibt?
Also ich wollte erstmal nicht in Abrede stellen, dass es nicht Menschen gibt, die daran glauben. Ich frage mich aber sozusagen in der Berichterstattung über Verschwörungserzählungen, wird sowas, wir kommen jetzt zu diesem Teil, wie gehen wir als Gesellschaft und als Medien vielleicht damit um, wird sowas, wie soll man das sagen, da wird darüber berichtet, weil halt eine große Zahl unter diesem Video steht. Ich glaube tatsächlich, Karolin, was du gerade angesprochen hast, das glaube ich schon, dass man guckt das und dann sieht man, also man ist eh anfällig, man guckt das, sieht das, hat eine Million andere Leute irgendwie auch geil gefunden. Dass man das eher als Verstärker war, das kann ich mir schon vorstellen. Ich meinte eher sozusagen dieses...
Journalistische Aufwertung.
Ja, also im Sinne von irgendwo gehen drei Leute auf die Straße und schreien drei Wochen lang hintereinander Ausländer raus. Und auf einmal werden die in Talkshows eingeladen. Und Tom Burrow ruft an. Und sozusagen so ein bisschen ähnlich sozusagen, ah, guck mal, das Echsenmenschen-Video, das hat eine Million Views. Lass uns doch gleich mal einen kleinen Artikel drüber machen. Und die Frage, ob die Verbreitung von Verschwörungserzählungen dadurch protegiert wird, dass sie überhaupt erst wahrgenommen werden, nur aufgrund von dem, dass da eine Zahl steht.
Ja, man muss vor allem, also einerseits glaube ich, das ist ein valider Punkt, dass man schauen muss, was wertet man überhaupt durch Berichterstattung auf? Und dann ist der nächste Punkt ja noch, wie berichtet man darüber? Das ist ja auch ein wichtiger Punkt, ne? Also man kann jetzt zum Beispiel ja sagen, QAnon hat vielleicht irgendwie am Ende 1000 Anhänger in Deutschland. Das ist jetzt noch nicht per se, und das ist eine komplett aus der Luft gegriffene Zahl, aber das ist per se jetzt noch nicht berichtenswert vielleicht. Aber es gibt zum Beispiel in den USA ja durchaus Fälle von Gewaltanwendung aus diesem Spektrum, und in dem Fall wäre das ja wieder eine Relevanz. Ich glaube aber, es ist unglaublich wichtig, sich von diesen Metriken zu verabschieden, aber das ist leider auch so ein oft gesagter Satz, den wir glaube ich seit Jahren immer wieder sagen. Und ich habe das zuletzt zum Beispiel gehabt bei diesem Thema Widerstand 2020, wo ich tatsächlich... Genau. Also es gab jetzt ganz kurz im Rahmen auch dieser Hygienedemos, sogenannten Hygienedemos, eine angeblich neue Partei, die jetzt irgendwie alle unter einem Hut versammelt. Und wir hatten vorhin schon das Thema, dass es relativ schwierig ist, Menschen mit sehr gegensätzlichen Theorien wirklich zusammen zu organisieren. Und diese angebliche neue Partei hat relativ große Zahlen in die Welt getragen und hat eben gesagt, sie haben irgendwie zehntausende Mitglieder schon nach kurzer Zeit. Und ich habe tatsächlich alle Interviewanfragen als Expertin dazu abgelehnt. Und glaube auch, dass es richtig war und dass wir das vielleicht auch aus der Sicht sowohl als Expertin zum Thema als auch als Journalistin, würde ich sagen, man kann da auch einfach teilweise deutlich länger abwarten. Weil am Ende stellt sich heraus, laut eines Videos, das jetzt gerade ein paar Tage alt ist, sie haben tatsächlich irgendwie unter 100 verifizierte Mitglieder. Und ein Organisationsgrad, der irgendwie berichtenswert wäre, hat sich bei mir da schon nicht zu der Zeit irgendwie dargestellt. Das ist jetzt kein Verschwörungsideologisches Thema, aber es ist damit verbunden und es zeigt so ein bisschen, dass man schnell dabei ist, tatsächlich Zahlen für sich anzunehmen und dann zu sagen, dadurch ergibt sich Relevanz. Das sehen wir auch bei allem, was irgendwie Stimmungsmache, teilweise auch organisierte Stimmungsmache gegen einzelne Journalisten, gegen einzelne Satirevideos oder sonstiges betrifft. Also da lässt man sich relativ schnell in vielen Redaktionen noch in die Irre führen, würde ich sagen.
Also eine Standardfrage bei mir in den letzten Wochen bei Interviews war eben auch so, ja sehen Sie eine Spaltung der Gesellschaft? Und dann wusste ich halt auch nicht irgendwie, okay, leben wir eigentlich in derselben Realität, habe ich mich dann schon manchmal gefragt, weil, naja, also ganz ehrlich bei anderen Themen wie beispielsweise zum Thema Seenotrettung, sind Zehntausende in ganz Deutschland, über 100.000 Menschen auf die Straße gegangen. Die Berichterstattung war im Vergleich zu jetzt eher so meh. Umfragen zeigen, dass es eben auch für viele Menschen ein Thema ist. Und trotzdem wurde da jetzt nicht gesagt, ok, darüber müssen wir jetzt drei Wochen berichten, was ich im Umbringen sehr schade fand. Und wenn man sich jetzt diese Demonstration anguckt, sind es halt in manchen Städten halt ein paar Dutzend Leute, aber hat einen hohen Skurrilitätsfaktor. Und natürlich ist es auch so, dass die Zahlen aus Umfragen, aus Studien hergeben, also es gibt einen Anteil in der Bevölkerung, der das glaubt. Aber das ist jetzt nicht etwas, das neu ist. Also das gab es schon immer und es gab es auch schon immer, dass politische Bewegungen das für sich versuchen zu nutzen, als Mittel der Radikalisierung oder der Mobilisierung. Und das jetzt zu einer Spaltung hochzuschreiben würde, auch diesen Gruppen viel mehr Macht zu schreiben, als sie eigentlich haben. Ja, also ich meine, das Mobilisierungspotenzial für ein Wochenende oder zwei Wochenende ist nur eine Sache. Die Frage ist halt eben, hat das Dauer? Da würde ich halt eher sagen, bin ich erst mal skeptisch aus den genannten Gründen der fehlenden Gemeinsamkeiten? Und Spaltung der Gesellschaft, das fand ich halt ehrlich gesagt unmöglich, dass es dann auch so in einigen Berichten dann als das dargestellt war. Das ist es aus meiner Sicht überhaupt.
Vielleicht können wir gleich zu der Frage kommen, was ist denn eure Erwartung an Journalismus? Wie jetzt mit Verschwörungserzählungen und rechtsextremer Desinformationen, das würde ich wirklich einfach jetzt in einen Topf werfen, umgegangen werden soll in Zukunft? Ich muss normalerweise aber von diesem Interview mit Simone Raphael erzählen, die hat bei Belltower News auch einen Kommentar geschrieben zu dem Thema und meint, sie fühlt sich eigentlich jetzt gerade so ein bisschen an die Anfänge von Pegida, im Sinne von, wenige Leute machen viel Krach und finden überall statt. Und ihr habt jetzt gerade auch schon erzählt, dass man da schon vorsichtig sein muss, also macht man es überhaupt. Und dann ist es aber auch so, es gar nicht machen ist wahrscheinlich keine Option, deswegen von euch als Expertinnen, wie macht man es am besten? Erst mal nur Journalismus.
Also ich glaube, es ist wichtig darüber zu berichten, aber man muss das auch nicht alles live tickern, sondern eigentlich ist vielmehr die Frage, was passiert da? Gibt es da Übergriffe? Was für Menschen gibt es da? Und das reicht auch, wenn man das jetzt nicht jede Woche macht, tatsächlich, sondern sich vielleicht auch mal langfristig anguckt. Ich glaube, diese Ausgeruhtheit fehlt da und die fehlt an vielen Ecken im Journalismus ja immer wieder. Das ist ja nichts Neues. Also es ist wichtig zu sagen, wer organisiert sich da und wer mischt sich darunter, finde ich. Es ist wichtig zu sagen, dass da zum Beispiel auch nicht nur Rechtsextreme unterwegs ist. Das kann man sagen. Man kann aber auch gleichzeitig sagen, dass sie keine Anstalten unternehmen, größtenteils sich von Rechtsextremen, von NS-Fahrharmlosern zu distanzieren. Das sind alles wichtige Punkte. Aber ich hab jetzt auch ganz oft gesehen, dass irgendwie Promis, die vor Ort waren, irgendeine Rolle gespielt haben. Und dass das so ein bisschen Boulevardesque wurde. Also das halte ich für den absolut falschen Weg. Und ich glaube, es ist auch falsch, sich als Ministerpräsident eines gewissen Bundeslandes mit einem Aluhut-Träger, also einem sprichwörtlichen Aluhut-Träger in der Diskussion zu zeigen. Weil das eben auch eine gleichzeitig Aufwertung von teilweise wirklich abstrusen Erzählungen ist.
Kattascha?
Die Gleichsetzung, die wir auch im Bereich Klima ja schon seit Ewigkeiten haben. Dass man irgendwie gleichwertig false equivalence hat und irgendwie sagt, naja wir diskutieren jetzt mal so, als wären das alles gleichwertige, wissenschaftsbasierte Annahmen, die da diskutiert werden.
Hast du da im Subtext quasi gerade schon auch gesagt, man soll so eine Leute auch nicht in Talkshows einladen?
Also ja, Talkshows ist immer glaube ich noch mal ein ganz anderes Thema, über das man vielleicht noch mal reden sollte. Also da gibt es ja noch ein paar andere Missstände. Furchtbarerweise.
Ja, also das Stichwort nicht einladen. Das finde ich ist tatsächlich ein wichtiges, weil ich meine, gut, jetzt haben wir die Debatte über die Demonstration, ist halt die Frage, wie lange das halt noch ein relevantes Phänomen ist, beziehungsweise wie lange das als relevantes Phänomen wahrgenommen wird, wie lange darüber berichtet wird. Aber wir hatten ja auch in den letzten Jahren immer wieder Situationen, dass auch Politiker, gerade von der AfD, regelmäßig in Talkshows eingeladen wurden, die an anderer Stelle richtig krasse Verschwörungserzählungen verbreitet haben. Stichwort Umvolkung, großer Austausch. Und da ist meine Position einfach, wer so etwas verbreitet, der hat sich von einer rationalen Debatte über Migration einfach schon längst verabschiedet. Also würde ich persönlich, wenn ich die Einladungsliste zusammenstellen würde, würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, das ist ein Gast. Also ich sag auch manchmal bei Talksendungen zu entsprechenden Themen, sag ich halt auch vorher so ja, frage ich immer, wer der Gast ist, weil je nachdem, wer da sitzt, dann würde ich halt auch sagen, so wichtig ist mir das nicht. Also ich musste halt mit niemanden von der AfD sitzen. Echt nicht. Und also ich finde momentan so die Situation zwiespältig, weil also natürlich diese Proteste werden aus meiner Sicht auch so ein bisschen überzeichnet, auch weil sie einen hohen Skurrilitätsgrad haben. Gleichzeitig bilden sie aber etwas ab, was viele Menschen in ihrem Umfeld auch beobachten. Dass halt Menschen plötzlich Verschwörungserzählungen verbreiten, denen man das vorher nicht zugetraut hätte. Und da finde ich das auch gut, wenn man auch gesellschaftlich vielleicht auch drüber diskutiert, wie geht man damit um, auch im privaten Umfeld, wenn man da beispielsweise stärker auch mal Beratungsstellen fragt, statt dem zehnten Bericht über die kleine Demo mit dem großen Skurrilitätsfaktor, vielleicht mal mit der Sektenberatungsstelle sprechen, was die eigentlich Angehörigen raten würden. Weil ich glaube, das würde ziemlich viele Leser interessieren. Ich würde gar nicht davon ausgehen, dass es jetzt irgendwie weniger Klicks produzieren würde. Und auch Wissenschaftler öfter mal zu Wort kommen lassen. Ich finde gerade in der Corona-Debatte fand ich das ganz angenehm, dass man da halt auch sehr stark Wissenschaftler im voller Grund hatte und da auch in weiten Teilen auch sachliche Debatte hat. Was bringt was, was bringt was nicht? Es ist eine neue Studie, die zeigt wieder was anderes. Gut, muss die alte revidiert werden. So ist Wissenschaft halt. Und da eben auch, sage ich mal, das als wissenschaftliches Phänomen irgendwo betrachten, wo es ja auch eine jahrzehntelange Vorarbeit gab. Da freue ich mich auch wirklich, dass meine Co-Autorin Pia Lamberte, die ja auch zu dem Thema forscht, zahlreiche Fachartikel in Pia Reviewed Zeitschriften veröffentlicht hat zum Thema mit Studien und so weiter, dass sie halt auch momentan sehr stark angefragt wird. Weil das, finde ich, auch der Problematik gerecht wird, dass man eben nicht sagt, so hoch, wo kommen die denn jetzt seit zwei Wochen her, sondern wirklich, wie ist die Genese dieses Milieus in den letzten Jahrzehnten?
Glaubt ihr, ich hänge jetzt gerade so ein bisschen dran, also Journalismus soll berichten und aber auch aufklären und sozusagen zur Seite stehen und begleiten. Und ich bin jetzt gerade irgendwie im Hängen geblieben am Anfang, dass du gesagt hast, dass man, oder es einen Zusammenhang gibt zwischen gesellschaftlich sicherer Stelle oder unsicherer. Je unsicherer sozusagen, desto mehr Übereinstimmung gibt es auch mit Verschwörungserzählungen. Glaubst du, dass Bildung trotzdem helfen kann, vor Verschwörungserzählungen zu schützen? Oder ist es, braucht es eher eine sicherere Gesellschaft? Und die Bildung spielt eigentlich gar nicht so eine Rolle. Weil Bildung, sozusagen Bildung hilft nicht vorm Kontrollverlust.
Ja, sagen wir mal so, ich hätte mich sehr gefreut, wenn ich in der Schule mehr zu Thema Psychologie als Unterrichtsfach gehabt hätte. Also später im Studium hatte ich halt viel zum Thema, ja weiß ich nicht, sogenannte Anomalies. Also sag ich mal, wo gibt es psychologische Effekte, die dafür sorgen, dass wir uns in einer bestimmten Art und Weise verhalten oder nicht verhalten. Was ja auch ganz oft in marktrelevanten Situationen so eine Sache ist. Beispielsweise, dass man eher so eine Loss-Aversion, also Verlustangst hat. Oder dass es halt bestimmte Urteils-Heuristiken gibt, die dazu führen, dass wir verzerrte Wahrnehmungen in einigen Bereichen haben. Also nicht objektiv-rationale, vor allem eigentlich fast in allen Bereichen genauer gesagt. Und so eine Grundbildung, würde ich sagen, persönlich, fände ich total geil, wenn man das in der Schule hätte. Und wenn ich beispielsweise weiß, dass ich in bestimmten Situationen einfach anfälliger für bestimmte Dinge bin, dann kann ich vielleicht auch mich selber reflektieren in solchen Situationen. Und hab vielleicht noch so einen letzten Moment, der mir einen halt gebietet, bevor ich da halt total auf diesen Zug aufspringe. Und natürlich gibt es so in allen Bereichen diese Tendenz, alles auf den Lehrplan zu packen, so nach dem Motto, das können wir lösen, indem wir den Lehrplan einfach noch mehr aufwerten. Aber ich würde tatsächlich sagen, so eine psychologische Grundbildung, die fände ich wirklich in ziemlich vielen Bereichen ziemlich geil. Und dafür würde ich auch auf die ein oder andere, weiß ich nicht, Gedichtinterpretation auch durchaus verzichten wollen.
Die Deutschlehrerinnen der Welt schreien auch.
Wenn ich Gourmails von Germanisten bekomme, ja oder meinetwegen halt auch im Bereich Mathematik oder Physik. Also ist halt auch alles wichtig, aber Psychologie hat man halt in ziemlich wenigen Bereichen. Und das finde ich schade, weil eigentlich, wenn man sich anguckt, welche Rolle das bei unseren Entscheidungen spielt, immens. Und es gibt auch Unterrichtsmaterial, beispielsweise von der Amadeo-Antonio-Stiftung, wo sie eben hingegangen sind und gesagt haben, naja, wie sprechen wir mit Schulklassen über Verschwörungserzählungen? Da war halt eben so ein Konzept, dass man sagt, naja, dann denkt euch beispielsweise welche aus und guckt euch gemeinsam an, was sind so Mechanismen? Und wenn ich das mal selber durchgespielt habe, dann erkenne ich das auch eher, wenn mir das über den Weg läuft. Es gibt spielerische Ansätze, es gibt Computerspiele, wo man quasi selber so ein Informationsvirus bauen muss, der sich dann verbreitet. Also Studien zeigen, dass es halt ultra effektiv ist, um bei Kindern und Jugendlichen dazu anzuregen, dass sie so etwas eher erkennen und dann auch eher so eine Art Frühwarnung.
Tatsächlich aber auch bei Älteren. Also es gibt von der Uni Cambridge ein Spiel, das auch gerade eher ältere Menschen, die durchaus Falschmeldungen und auch Verschwörungsideologien verbreiten, auch gespielt haben. Und bei denen war das auch teilweise besonders wirksam. Und was mir in dem Bereich bildet und immer noch wichtig ist, ist, dass wir auch endlich noch mal viel mehr über Menschen reden, die nicht über das Schulsystem erreichbar sind, weil wir da einfach überhaupt keine vernünftigen Lösungen haben. Also das reicht eben nicht, da nur über die VHS zu gehen, wo eh nur Leute hingehen, die eh schon sich mit dem Thema auseinandersetzen wollen. Und mir fehlt das total im journalistischen, im politischen, im alltäglichen Diskurs, dass wir das mal wirklich anpacken und darüber reden. Weil ich so das Gefühl hab, wir lassen jetzt einfach alle Generationen, die nicht mehr zur Schule gehen, einfach mal machen und hoffen, dass es dann mit der nächsten, sobald der Bildungsplan oder Lehrplan dann irgendwie entsprechend eingepasst ist, was dann sowieso erst in den nächsten who knows wann Jahren passiert. Also das finde ich unglaublich wichtig, das auch immer noch zu betonen, weil es gibt eigentlich kaum bis keine vernünftigen Angebote, die ich auch einfach mal zur Hand an die Hand geben würde. Weil es fängt ja auch schon bei Lehrern an, die eigentlich gar nicht wissen, wie sie mit dem Internet umzugehen haben, die teilweise auch Selbstverschwörungsideologien verbreiten. Also da ist reichlich zu tun an ganz vielen Stellen.
Also Bildung gar nicht so sehr als Aufklärung gegen die Verschwörungserzählung, also faktische, sondern eher für die Mechanismen breitmachen und aufklären und Impulskontrolle im Selbst ermöglichen, sage ich mal. Das ist ja, also sowohl dieses Bildungs- als auch Deutons-Thema, das ist ja gesellschaftlicher Kontext. Also da reden wir über das große Ganze. Was mich berührt hat, war Kattascha, ein Thread von dir, wo du gesagt hast, ich weiß, der ist jetzt schon ein paar Wochen alt, wo du gesagt hast, der für mich so hängen geblieben ist, als die Menschen, die in der Nähe von Menschen sind, die in Verschwörungserzählungen abgeleiten. Das sind ganz wichtige Bausteine in dem Schutz, oder in dem möglicherweise das zu verhindern, dass es endgültig passiert. Wie macht man das, wenn man das bei sich beobachtet?
Ja, zunächst einmal ist es immer schwierig, sag ich mal. Wir haben im Bezug darauf mit Beratungsstellen gesprochen, die eben auch mit Angehörigen zu tun haben, die sich dann recht verzweifelt an sie wenden und sagen, naja, irgendwie mein Partner hat sich verändert, meine Schwester hat sich verändert. Und wir haben auch mit Angehörigen gesprochen von Menschen, die an Verschwörungen glauben, die halt wirklich auch verzweifelt waren. Die uns berichtet haben, dass beispielsweise Angehörige dann sich bei einer schweren Erkrankung nicht mehr behandeln lassen wollen. Also wo man wirklich Angst hat, dass derjenige stirbt, weil er eben an eine Verschwörung der Schulmedizin war, angeblich eine Schulmedizin glaubt. Also Schulmedizin ist ja auch ein schwieriger Begriff aus diesem Umfeld, hat auch so eine recht braune Vergangenheit, muss man dazu wissen. Und also grundsätzlich muss man sich darauf einstellen, dass es eher ein Marathon als ein Sprint ist. Weil oft muss man, also oft wird man erst darauf aufmerksam, dass jemand da in so ein Milieu abgerutscht ist oder in so eine apokalyptische Gedankenwelt, wenn das recht weit fortgeschritten schon ist. Also dann wird es halt plötzlich dann am Essentisch ausgesprochen und oft hat man so den Impuls, boah, ich will jetzt echt keinen Stress am Familientisch, ist jetzt gerade so beschaulich, heute streiten wir uns mal nicht, lassen wir das mal so. Und das Problem ist, dass Beratungsstellen ja wirklich sagen, das ist der falsche Weg. Je früher man eingreift, desto besser. Weil meistens ist es so, dass man in so ein Sog gerät. Also gerade wenn man sich über bestimmte Quellen, bestimmte Influencer informiert, dann ist es manchmal so, dass diese Akteure sich teilweise auch in dieser Zeit radikalisieren. Das beobachtet man ja auch bei einigen, die jetzt so zum Thema Corona so jetzt sehr hervorgehoben sind, wo man das Gefühl hat, so okay, jeden Monat sind die noch mal im Level weiter. Andererseits wird man ja auch auf andere Akteure aufmerksam, die halt immer noch mal einen Schritt weitergehen. Das heißt, von der, sag ich mal, irgendwie, dass man sagt, so ja, an dem Thema Impfen, da ist halt so ein bisschen was dran. Kann es halt sein, dass man über Akteure, die dann dazu schreiben, halt irgendwann wirklich zu Gruppen kommt, die behaupten, so es gibt halt eine geheime Weltregierung und die unterdrückt jetzt hier Wissen. Und an der Stelle ist es dann wirklich fast zu spät mit einem, oder eigentlich zu spät mit einem Faktencheck zu kommen, weil dann halt so dieses Argument ist so ja, das Faktencheck von der, das ist doch von der Presse, die ist doch Teil der Verschwörung, glaube ich nicht. Wissenschaft auch, dasselbe. Das heißt, je früher eingreift, desto besser, weil am Anfang, wenn die Leute noch so in diesen unterschiedlichen Informationswelten sind, kann man noch am ehesten zu ihnen durchdringen. Und wenn es halt wirklich so ist, dass der Glaube halt wirklich sehr weit fortgeschritten ist und man auch so das Gefühl hat, dass es so eine allumfassende Welterklärung geworden ist, dann helfen meistens halt nur noch Fragen. Also wirklich vorsichtig vorantasten und wirklich immer wieder hinterfragen, warum glaubst du das, woher weißt du das, ist der Experte, warum ist der Experte, warum glaubst du, der ist mehr Experte als der andere Experte. Also einfach nur Fragen stellen, damit der andere das selbst reflektiert und auch nicht das Gefühl hat, dass man von oben herab mit ihm spricht. Also auch wenn es oft anstrengend ist, dann halt nicht laut werden, nicht ungeduldig werden, auf gar keinen Fall von oben herab belehrend. Und da halt wirklich immer am Ball bleiben. Und manchmal kann es halt auch einfach nur helfen zu fragen, so hör mal, wie geht es dir eigentlich? Also Stichwort Kontrollverlust. Also gerade wenn wir doch wissen aus wissenschaftlichen Studien, dass Krisen ein Katalysator dafür sein können, dass Menschen halt sich so verändern, dann kann es ja auch sein, dass wenn ich diese Krise versuche zu lindern oder wegzunehmen, dass dann dieser Drang zur Flucht in so eine Fantasiewelt gar nicht mehr so groß ist. Und zumindest in einigen Fällen kann das klappen. Und vor allem, wenn ich so eine emotionale Brücke zu jemandem aufbaue, dann kann ich darüber ja auch später viel eher argumentativ gehen. Wobei man gleichzeitig sagen muss, man muss halt an vielen Stellen da halt auch wirklich eine rote Linie ziehen. Beispielsweise Antisemitismus, Rassismus. Das muss man ganz klar als solches benennen. Da sollte man auf gar keinen Fall schweigen oder halt denken, ich darf das jetzt nicht eskalieren. An der Stelle muss man auch eskalieren, weil da geht es eben auch um andere. Und man muss an irgendeiner Stelle sich auch fragen, so schaffe ich das? Also einige Angehörige, die sagen dann halt auch, wir haben den Kontakt irgendwann abgebrochen, weil es nicht mehr ging. Weil wir beispielsweise unsere Kinder auch davor schützen wollten, dass sie Kontakt mit den Reichsbürgern haben. Weil diese Leute auch teilweise auch irgendwann aggressiv werden können, wenn sie glauben, dass man Teil der Verschwörung ist. Und im Zweifel sollte man sich da auch Hilfe suchen. Also Verbündete im Umfeld, Freunde, Familie oder eben auch Beratungsstellen. Und da würde ich wirklich dazu raten, Sektenberatungsstellen gibt es in unterschiedlichen Bundesländern, auch in der Schweiz, Österreich. Die haben viel Erfahrung damit, weil es eben diese Überschneidung gibt, zu vielen Sekten-Gurus, die dann Verschwörungserzählungen verbreiten. Oder eben mobile Beratungen gegen Rechtsextremismus beim Thema Reichsbürger.
Aber das heißt, es gibt schon einen Unterschied in der Art, wie wir als Gesellschaft, im Großen und Ganzen, und als Medien damit umgehen und im Privaten, nämlich dieses Verständnis zeigen. Als ich das zum ersten Mal gehört habe, hat sich mir der Widerspruch aufgemacht, was sich Pegida zu Nutze gemacht hat, ist, wir sind die besorgten Bürger. Das ist ja eben genau dieses Verständnis einfordern. Das kann im Privaten also funktionieren, aber man kann es nicht als gesellschaftliche Strategie annehmen.
Ich glaube, es gibt schon...
Man muss unterscheiden, ganz klar zwischen... Vielleicht noch diesen einen Punkt. Man muss an der Stelle ganz klar unterscheiden zwischen öffentlich und privat. Das, was ich eben geschildert habe, ist ein Feld in meinem Umfeld, an meinem Essenstisch, ein Verwandter oder ein enger Freund. Was anderes ist, wenn ich das online sehe, in der Öffentlichkeit sehe, da ist Gegenrede absolut wichtig. Da muss man auch ganz klar hier einen Fakten checken. Es ist egal, ob ich das gegenüber überzeuge. Das will ich gar nicht. Ich will den stillen Mitglädern zeigen, dass ich nicht der Meinung bin. Ich muss auch nicht als Ministerpräsident hingehen und mit den Leuten verständnisvoll sprechen. Ich bin nicht der Angehörige, ich bin der Ministerpräsident. Das sind eben diese unterschiedlichen Rollen. Wenn ich aber meinen Gegenüber wirklich überzeugen will und nicht in eine öffentliche Debatte gehe, dann sind Vier-Augen-Gespräche einfach wichtig. Da muss man aber auch klar trennen. Es schließt sich nicht aus, dass ich im Familienchat Onkel Heinrich ganz klar sage, das ist hier antisemitisches Zeug, hier Faktencheck. Sorry, geht gar nicht. Entweder du hörst damit auf oder du fliegst aus dem Familienchat und gleichzeitig den später anrufen und sagen, wie kommt es eigentlich dazu, dass du so was verbreitest? Es können gleichzeitig Strategien sein. Bei der einen geht es darum, Dritte zu schützen oder zu verhindern, dass derjenige das in einer großen Gruppe ausbreitet. Gerade bei Rassismus, Antisemitismus, das kann einfach zu Gewalt führen gegen Menschen.
Nein, das kam jetzt zum Ende tatsächlich noch mal. Was mir auch noch mal wichtig war, glaube ich, zu sagen, dass es bei beiden eben auch diese Grenzen gibt. Dass man eben Entmenschlichungen und Antisemitismus, Antisemitismus, antimuslimischen Rassismus und so weiter eben nicht zulässt. Dass es eben bei beiden gleich nur, dass man eben in Sachen Aufwertung und gleichwertiger Darbietung von Meinungen in dem Medium noch viel, viel mehr vorsichtig sein muss und auch aufpassen muss, inwiefern man anerkennt, dass das eben eine kleine, sehr laute Minderheit ist, der man da jetzt sehr, sehr viel Raum gibt.
Und damit sind wir am Ende dieser Erzählung angekommen. Würde ich sagen, wenn ihr beiden nicht noch sozusagen ein letztes Wort habt, dass ihr an die Werte Gemeinde richten wollt als Kultleiterin des Chaosradios für heute?
Ja, als Kultleiterin wünsche ich mir möglichst bald möglichst viel 5G in Berlin, damit dieser Horror mit abbrechenden Telefonverbindungen und Videostreams und was man nicht gesehen hat, endlich ein Ende hat.
Das Internet ist nicht die Lösung. Das Internet ist nicht die Lösung, zumindest aktuell nicht.
Okay, vielen Dank, dass ihr beide heute hier wart und so ausführlich mit mir darüber gesprochen habt. Karolin Schwarz, Hasskrieger, der neue globale Rechtsextremismus ist das Buch. Du hast eigentlich auch einen Podcast, also bist Teil eines Podcasts, Filterbabel. Wie läuft, lohnt es sich noch, den zu abonnieren? Kann man da bald wieder was hören?
Unklar aktuell.
Viel zu tun. Viel zu tun, na gut, aber du hast ihn noch nicht aufgegeben? Und Katharina Nocuni zusammen mit Pia Lamberti das Buch Fake Facts wie Verschwörungstheorien unser Denken bestimmen, gerade rausgebracht hat und auch einen Podcast hat, nämlich Denkangebot. Wie sieht es da aus?
Ja, das Problem ist, ich habe eigentlich das Material für die nächste Folge Zeit genommen. Und ich habe noch voll Stress gemacht, hier müssen wir das Interview machen und jetzt habe ich sechs total geile Interviewpartnerinnen gehabt und wurde dann wegen dem Buch etwas vom Medieninteresse überrascht und hoffentlich habe ich bald Zeit daraus eine ganz tolle Folge zum Thema Corona zu machen.
Alles klar, also bleibt dran, folgt den beiden, wo immer ihr kennt, in den Show Notes werden die passenden Links dazu stehen. Vielen Dank nochmal, dass ihr hier wart. Ich sage an dieser Stelle schon mal Tschüss.
Tschüss, hast's gut.
Und liebe Hörerinnen, für euch sage ich wie immer noch ganz zum Schluss, lasst ihr nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.